hi I'm Peter Domingos I'm a professor of
computer science at the University of
Washington and machine learning
researcher probably best known as the
author of The Master algorithm Popular
Science introduction to machine learning
I'm here at nurits 2022 of the vast
amounts of stuff that's happening here
the two that I found most interesting
and are closest to my own research are
neurosymbolic Ai and symmetry based
learning
okay Professor Pedro Domingos it's an
absolute honor to have you back on the
show Pedro is a professor at the
University of Washington and give us a
quick introduction to yourself to your
experience here at Europe so far and
what's top of mind for you
I'm a machine learning researcher I've
worked in most of the major areas I've
also written a popular science book on
machine learning called the master
algorithm I'm having a lot of fun here
at nips listening to various talks like
David Charmers on Consciousness and and
Jeff hit non-sleep and you know looking
forward to the rest of it awesome I'd
love to get your thoughts on charmism in
in a bit actually but um the first thing
I wanted to talk about just because it's
top of mind is this whole Galactica
situation so um first of all I was
speaking with Ian the other day and I
think it's a little bit unfair that meta
really bear the brunt of this openai
have just released this new chat GPT
um Bots which you know suffers from
similar failure modes and it just kind
of feels that they're not getting
anywhere near as much stick as meter is
well I think that I agree with you I
think the brouhaha about Galactica is
way overblown
that system is really largely harmless
it's just another large language model
that's designed for actually something
that to me as a scientist is very
interesting right I would love to have a
system like that to help me out with
certain things and I think it's a step
in the right direction and and I think
the bruja however is an instance of
people jumping the gun on a lot of these
AI things in a way that to me is very
excessive having said that in a way they
set themselves up for it in a way that
they need and have they kind of over
claimed what it did and like the problem
with this with these llms is that they
generate a lot of stuff that looks good
but can be completely wrong and in a way
there's no worse place to do that than
in writing scientific articles so when
they came up with it they should have
been more careful about the how they
framed it I think the two concerns are
like this competition and one-upping
each other on her come up so it comes up
with the you know with the frilliest
demo and and that kind of backfired so
they shouldn't have had to you know
withdraw it I think it's that that's all
pathetic and hopefully they've you know
they've learned the lesson that next
time they will do it slightly
differently yes okay okay well um so
Gary Marcus has been very loud about
this on on Twitter so he he's he's
really pushing the point about
misinformation and the thing is as well
I don't want to
um characterize the ethics folks as
having monolithic views because they
don't have monolithic views and I also
think that a lot of the um the ethics
guidelines for large language models are
very reasonable like I I interviewed the
CEO of coher the other week Aiden Gomez
I went through their terms and
conditions and policies all very
reasonable the only sticking point for
me is the misinformation one I I think
the the kind of the moral valence of it
is in its use right and and especially
with misrepresentation I don't like this
paternalism telling me what's good for
me I've just lost out on using a really
cool tool basically I mean I completely
agree with you I'll take it even further
I do not want other people deciding from
me what is misinformation and what is
therefore allowed to be said because
it's misinformation or not for a couple
of reasons one is that these people who
claim to be big critics of
misinformation a lot of them are
misinformers themselves
and the bottom line is that you always
have your ideology that you know informs
what you think is true and false and I
don't want anybody every one of us in a
democracy should be deciding for
themselves
what is true and what is false and what
is well then what isn't and I have no
fear of attempts to misinform me as long
as I have a multiplicity of sources
right the biggest misinformation danger
is what is when you have only one
monolithic source of truth whatever it
is which is unfortunately what a lot of
these anti-misinformation people I think
consciously or unconsciously want give
me you know 10 things nine of which are
misinformation I can do the job of
figuring out which one I think is valid
give me only one of those things and
chances are nine and ten that it is
misinformation and then I have no chance
to overcome it so this whole attack on
things because they misinformation and I
mean I understand the impulse that like
why have all this falsehood flying
around but the way to overcome that
falsehood is not by censoring it you
should know this right we shouldn't be
having to re-fight all of this over
again in the context of social media and
I know and and large language models and
so on
so you said something really interesting
which is that this notion of a pure
truth or a monolithic truth and there's
this concept of um you know epistemic um
subjectivity right or you know things
observe a relative even um complex
phenomena like intelligence no one
understands what it is you can't reduce
it to one particular thing people have
different views on it right so this
notion that that there is a pure
monolithic truth of the world I I think
is it's horrifying well I would I would
put it slightly differently
um
so first of all there's a question is
there one reality or not right is there
truth or is there my truth and your
truth right I actually
I understand the impulse to talk about
my truth and your truth but I think as a
so what is really true we don't know but
as a I think the most useful including
socially useful working hypothesis is
that there is a single reality and the
single truth but it's extremely complex
so not none of no single one of us can
get at it so what we need is many
different people coming at it from
different angles but with the premise
that we need to try to make these things
consistent so just saying oh we have
different truths and there's no reality
that is actually very counterproductive
because it gives everybody a pass to
just believe whatever wacky thing they
want and then the consequences of that
when you have to make the realizations
are very bad at the same time I agree
with you if if if if I think that I have
access to that truth I know everybody
just needs to you know count out to it
that is very dangerous so I think we
need to entertain these two ideas that
there is a truth but it's very complex
and no one has a monopoly on it and the
key is you know like objective truth is
what different observers can agree on
and now we can figure out what it is
that we agree on and that way we we make
progress in understanding reality and we
also tend to make more of the right
decisions because we're closer to the
truth okay but do you do you see it as I
mean I think the reality thing is is
interesting but do you just see it
cynically as gatekeeping
as in having a clerical class controller
oh absolutely no absolutely I mean and
if that that's precisely the danger that
I was referring to is that if you let me
put it this way
if ever there is and this is a commonly
mooded proposal right then not even
proposed like are we going to have a
truth Commission of people who decide
what is true on whatever Twitter or
something right that is that that is a
really alarming thing because there is
no commission that can do that what
they're going to do is they're going to
impose their version of reality and
everybody else which unfortunately is
what a lot of these people want to do
they convince that they have the truth
and they want to impose it on the rest
of us and that is really alarming we
know historically what happens when
people succeed in doing that yes yes but
I suppose my point with the gatekeeping
is it almost gets you to the actual
truth of the matter is irrelevant it's
actually about power but what's your
take on I don't know whether you think
this is putting it too strongly but this
being a form of industrial
um kind of gaslighting okay yeah kind of
you know in an allwellian sense trying
to shape people's reality through you
know language culture and and
interactions on the internet
I think a lot of it is deliberate uh
some of it is I mean
I'm an optimist about human nature at
the end of the day uh maybe in you know
maybe with justification maybe without I
think so there's this postmodern view
that it's all about power and it's
certainly partly about power but I think
a lot of the people doing this
unfortunately or maybe fortunately they
are they're not seeking power for its
own sake they they have a set of beliefs
that they think is right and then the
means you know the unjustify the means
right that's the problem so that gate
heaping you know and that gaslighting
happened not because not for their own
sake they happen for the sake of a cause
I know there's two problems with this is
that these days the causes of for on
behalf of which this is being done in my
view are largely wrong right but whether
they're right or wrong right the problem
is that this is just noxious in its own
right and also then a lot of sort of
like
again personal desire for power and
promotion and prevailing over others
then of course you know he just arrived
on to this yeah interesting I mean we'll
get we'll get into consequentialism um
in in a minute because I think there's
quite an interesting uh Journey we can
go there but I wanted to cite Francois
chole uh I'm a big fan of him he just
tweeted saying I'm not too concerned of
whether what I read is right or wrong I
can figure that part out myself I'm
interested in things that are useful
thought-provoking novel sometimes the
most creative thinkers have a bias
towards wrongness but they're still
worth reading would you agree with that
yes I largely agree with that so as as I
was saying before uh you know I can
tell for myself for I can do that
exercise of figuring out what is right
and wrong the most important thing that
I want is to not miss out on things that
I
don't want to miss out on like you know
the known unknowns and the unknown
unknowns the biggest killer is the
unknown unknown so the if any anybody
trying to learn or understand something
there for person or organization or
Society right if all they do is is move
the unknown unknowns to known unknowns
they've already gone an enormous
distance right and so I I appreciate
people who I disagree with first of all
because that's how you sharpen ideas
yeah but also because they they might
just bring things to my attention that
if we were all conforming to the
majority of you would not come to our
attention and then those more often than
not are the ones that kill you yeah
that's so interesting I mean there's a
real analogy here even this might be
tenuous but between symbolism and and
connectionism or You Know Rich Sutton
said we shouldn't be hand crafting our
AI systems we should kind of let them
emerge and it's a similar thing with our
moral framework but you're kind of
saying that it should be emergent from
low-level complexity and diversity and
interestingness and and there is another
school of thought which is that we
should be top down and we already have a
representation I actually think it
should be it needs to be a combination
yeah we need to have both this is one of
those debates that in some sense puzzles
me because to me the obvious answer is
that we need both and then and then and
if you read the master argument this is
what I do I look at the different
paradigms of machine learning and I
don't come out in favor of any of them
because actually I think we need ideas
from all of them and then we need to
combine them into something coherent and
like if you look at Psychology like you
bring this bottom up and top-down
processing and if it only did one of
them either one it wouldn't work and I
think as we try to build a larger
intelligence it's the same thing we
definitely need the bottom-up part and
you know by volume the volume the bottom
up part is going to be bigger so if you
could only have one that would probably
be you know the choice but the but the
but the top-down part is also very
important if you go all the way back the
top down part probably started this
bottom up and got synthesized and
improved but now we need that loop the
loop is actually very important well
that's interesting in in your book I
guess I want to sketch out different
types of AI architecture so you know you
get universalists this kind of deepmind
idea that are very simple underlying
algorithm could produce everything and
then you get um you know hybrid focus on
the other side of the spectrum and then
there's an integrated approach in the
middle like where would you kind of
place yourself from that continue I
would place myself very much in the
frame of mind uh well let me put it this
way I don't know but which is nobody
does right if somebody tells you that
they know how we're going to get to
intelligence you should be suspicious
right away but what do I think
is the most promising approach and the
one that ideally would be the best one
if we can pull it off it's there being a
single algorithm yeah so at that level I
very much sympathize with with what is
effectively deepmind's agenda now where
I part with a lot of these people is
that I don't think that the the the the
algorithm that we need is as simple as
many of those people think it is and I
don't think it exists it probably it is
probably the case that the algorithm
that we really need at the end of the
day doesn't even look that much that
like any of the things that we have now
so I think hopefully there is such an
algorithm but we're still far from it
interesting I mean they would cite
um the example of evolution as being a
very simple underlying algorithm
although Ken Stanley would say that and
people misunderstand evolution
so I agree with them at that level in
fact in the master algorithm I have a
chapter where I go over you know the
objections and the reasons to believe
that there is a master algorithm a lot
of the majority of the people even in
the field are skeptical of that notion
even though I would claim that
effectively that's what they're pursuing
people like Rich Sutton and Jeff hit and
I asked a bunch of people before I wrote
the book and they do believe in this
idea of having a master album A lot of
people believe that but intuitively a
lot of people believe that no it doesn't
there is no such thing right and I
I understand that intuition but I think
it's
well I think it's a well-founded
intuition let me put it that way but in
in a sense we know there is such a thing
we look at cellular automata look at
what we've already done with with deep
learning I I think the context is is
there such a thing that will produce
what we want well yeah so yeah to take
your you know your your example or or
who you know the mind's example of
evolution right yeah I do so in in the
book I mentioned empirical evidence that
there is a massive argument an exhibit
one is evolution right if you think of
evolution as an algorithm which by the
way is a very old idea I think it was
George boole that said you know God does
not create animals and plants he creates
the air the algorithm by which animals
and plants come about he didn't use the
word algorithm but that that's
essentially what he said this I think is
right on right and another example is
your brain
if the algorithm doesn't have to be
something as simple as as back prop and
you're a materialist like most of the
scientists are in your brain if if the
master argument is an algorithm that can
learn anything you do then your brain is
that algorithm right but then there's
another one which is even more
fundamental right but I think from the
point of view of this debate is very
Illuminating which is the laws of
physics
why stop at Evolution right the laws of
physics are the master algorithm right
evolution is very complicated in fact
what I think about you know evolution in
AI currently is that evolution in
reality is much more complex than we
give it credit for yeah which is why a
lot of our current generic algorithms
don't work that well but the laws of
physics at this level are much simpler
and if you think about it from the laws
of physics comes Evolution and comes all
the intelligence that we have
it's very intriguing why that happens
and why the laws are such that that
happens but even just the laws of
physics already in master dragon not
what you what you could say and many
people immediately says like oh but if
you start from there you know you'll
never get anywhere right but then you
can say like evolution is the laws of
physics sped up in a certain direction
and then our reinforcement learning is
like Evolution people have pointed out
the similar except it's faster and you
know what we're trying to do now in
machine learning is the same thing yet
again except only even faster
but what are the consequences of I mean
let's say um it is actually a very high
resolution algorithm so it's something
that appears to be completely
unintelligible to in respect of the
output phenomena is that is that even a
good place to be because you know just
like with cellular automata there's no
real paradigmatic relationship between
the underlying rules and the emerging
phenomena right so is that really even
something we want no I think there is so
we don't know
but I think people and this is very
common among connections to say this
stuff is also complex that we can't
possibly have a hand on it we just have
to let it happen and I think that is not
giving enough credit to to our human
brains right we are incredibly good at
making sense of things that in the
beginning don't I mean over and over and
over in the history of Science and
Technology you start out with things
that you don't understand very well at
all but then over time we kind of change
our representation of the world to make
those things actually be intelligible to
us and and we should not a priority
assume that that's not going to be the
case here so for example cellular
automata amazing things come out of
whatever the game of life that seem
completely disconnected from those but
they aren't right and you know you know
there's there's various depths at which
you to go you could go into this they
were probably at the end of the day be
some large element of this that we can't
figure out very well but we can figure
out enough that we have a handle on it
so this Singularity notion there at some
point I just completely beyond our
understanding I tend not to buy it I
don't think it will be completely beyond
our understanding but it's a an analogue
back to our Twitter discussion like
because we can only understand it
through it's like having views on a
mountain range you know the view looks
different depending on where you're
standing and it's the same thing with
with the emergent phenomena in a
cellular automata not very good and you
know the classic example of this is the
is the blind man and the elephants right
yeah and and that's that's actually the
metaphor that is in the book is I say
you know the different tribes are like
different Blind Men right but but
precisely so I is one of the blind man I
can see part of the elephant but it'd be
who's also talks to you who see another
part of the elephant and then each of us
understands a little bit more of the
elephant than we would if we were on our
own but most importantly we collectively
which is what really matters actually
understand maybe not the elephant
completely but much more of the elephant
than either one any of us would alone
right and and it's certainly a lot
better than just giving up and say like
oh we're never going to stand this
strange thing that's in front of us
interesting but that's a great argument
to what you were saying before so it's
beyond our cognitive Horizon therefore
we need to have diversity of aspect
there's a yes there's a question of it's
whether it's beyond the cognitive
ability of a single human yeah and then
there's the question of what's beyond
the cognitive ability of an entire
Society of humans and obviously there'll
be things that are beyond the cognitive
ability of a single human but not beyond
the connective ability of a society also
these days we have computers so our
cognitive power is augmented by our
machines so we can understand things or
bring things to the point where we
understand them to a degree today that
we couldn't a hundred years ago right
now that is a fascinating point so um
it's beyond our cognitive Horizon
individually but it might not be beyond
the cognitive Horizon of loads and loads
of humans on the internet you know the
wisdom of crowds but we don't I mean how
do we know that the crowd understands
well we never was well that's the the in
some sense the beauty of this right is
that we never what is the crowd really
understanding right and again once the
crowd is augmented by machines like
machine learning algorithms right we can
ask what do we as a society equipped
with all of our you know large language
models and so on and so forth what do we
really understand right now at some
level you can't answer that question
individually because you are just an
individual but right there's a couple of
very important things that that we
shouldn't forget one is that you could
one thing you can do and that I do do is
say like do I now actually even just
individually understand things better
than I did before when it was just me
looking at it and the answer to that is
almost invariably yes right so so there
is a big game to be Heather and the
second one is that you ultimately you
tell by the consequences right and like
for example take a deep Network right
and you may not know how it works but if
it's doing medical diagnosis you can
tell whether it you know gets the
diagnosis right more often than than it
did before or more often than another
model so we as a society may not you
know we individuals may not very
understand very well what we as a
society understand but we can see the
consequences and at some level that's
the point yeah so on that I mean that
sounds like a bit of an appeal to
behaviorism and I'm we're going to talk
about that in respect of Charmers as
well but um it also brings us back to
you know we were talking about
empiricism versus rationalism and
nativism and all of these topics um
would you place yourself in in that camp
of being a nativist and a rationalist or
completely the other way no absolutely
not again this is one of one of the
points that I uh you know go back to is
there are the imperial system there are
the rationalists and you could see
naively machine learning as being the
Triumph of the empiricists but it
actually is not there are very
fundamental reasons why it's not and I
really do think and and this is not just
think there's this thing called the no
free lunch Theory right and if you take
those things seriously the solution has
to be a combination of empiricism and
rationalism I don't think you decide the
loan has or even can have the whole
answer so very much we need both of
those and if you're a pure empiricist or
a pure rationalist I'm already
suspicious of you
wonderful
um coming back to what Francois said in
in his quote he said you know producing
things that are thought-provoking noble
and all the rest of it and I was
speaking to some alignment folks
yesterday and we'll pivot to that in a
minute but the big thing for me after
doing an episode on Souls the Chinese
room is you know where does
intentionality come from and Chomsky
talks about Agency for example we do
things that are appropriate to the
situation but not caused by them so from
my perspective all these generative
models all these large language models
and so on the creativity the the real
spark of Genius still comes from us
right we've just kind of like
um you know the the boring bit of
actually doing the task is is now um
delegated to the algorithm
I would disagree with that I think you
are um I mean your position is very
reasonable and actually I would say
probably the most common but I think
when you do that you are giving us too
much credit and the large language model
is too little we tend to have this
notion that creativity is something
magical in fact I remember for many
years so quick parenthesis in the
previous life I was a musician so you
know I in some sense know about and a
lot of my job was composing songs right
and I was always at the same time I was
already studying Ai and I couldn't help
but connect it too right and think about
like what would an AI look that was able
to compose music right and and
talking too late people who are not
musicians they think that composing
songs is some kind of magic thing that
comes from you know whatever the great
beyond and it's not yeah it's a very
human Enterprise and it can very well be
automated it's actually now you know
people I used to see people like
people always say like oh creativity
will be the last thing that we automate
because we humans can do it and there's
no machines could and be like no it's
going to be the opposite you'll automate
creativity long before many other things
and we're there now right in just the
last so I think when you let me put it
this way
your prompt to the llm let's say is like
the grain of sand to the oyster right
you should not give yourself credit for
having made the Pearl because you put
the grain of sand in there that's right
that's a brilliant analogy right so it
is it's still the LL we need to we want
we can critique how creative it is or
not and there's a lot to be said there
are a lot of progress to be made but but
we need to give you credit for what it
does right it is that well or not so
well right maybe it's more of an
illusion that we're giving you credit
for and what not but that text or that
image or whatever they were created yeah
by the AI and in many ways they think
that was created by the AI is no worse
than what would have been created by an
artist if I gave them the prompt that
okay well on on that I agree with you I
mean Melanie Mitchell had this wonderful
anecdote from the Googleplex when she
was with Douglas hofstadter and uh he
was talking at the time about you know
how he would be devastated if an AI
could produce a shopper uh piece you
know which was indistinguishable from
from one which he actually created and
of course that did happen yeah
um but then we get into this discussion
of um where does it start right where
does it start computers only do what we
tell them to do right they've been
trained and actually I was speaking to
um to sep about this as the other day
that you know all of the abstractions
all of the things that the computers and
the models do they are crystallized
snapshots of things that humans have
previously done and we've written the
computer Pro uh code so where does the
creativity start well uh but we by that
standard we humans also only do what
we're told to do
we'll do what we're told to do by our
genes our genes do what they're told to
do by Evolution which does what it's
told to do by the laws of physics right
right and now again this gets back to
this notion that there's nothing magical
about creativity creativity really is to
a large extent cutting and pasting stuff
and satisfying consistency constraints
between them and I'm not just saying
this in the after like long before the
modern era there's this guy called David
cope you know a professor of a composer
and professor of Music at UC Santa Cruz
who created these programs that exactly
they would write they can write this was
pre-machine learning right it was list
code that what it did was basically have
rules about how music should be and then
it takes Snippets and combines them
right you could say it's just parroting
those bits but the truth is at the end
of the day and you can choose this so
like give me something in the style of
Mozart and it creates something by that
looks indistinguishable from from what
Mozart did but all it's doing is this
kind of recombination of pieces so we
humans we we have too much respect for
appreciation of our own intelligence
that's also what we're doing
yeah I think I agree with you first of
all intelligence is a receding Horizon
and there's the mccordac effect exactly
I agree with all of that but um
yeah um I think it's a similar thing to
how we anthropomorphize um large
language models and and even you know
it's tempting to say large language
models are slightly conscious and we'll
talk about that in a minute but but
maybe like um we also anthropomorphize
our own agency right we have like a
little bubble around ourselves and we
kind of delude ourselves that we exist
as as an individual unit with agency
um disconnected from the rest of the
world well precisely the problem with
how we largely take AI today this has
always been the case by the way is that
we have a new resistible notion to
anthropomorphize anything that behaves
even remotely like us we're the only
intelligent things that we know so if
something starts to behaving
intelligently then we project onto it
all of these other human characteristics
same with Consciousness same with
creativity we don't know anything else
that's created besides us so once the
machine starts to behaving creatively we
cannot help but project a lot of things
onto it it's just reasoning by analogy
right so it's it's a kind of
analogicalness like you're like me in
this respect so you probably are in this
Southern spec now the good news is that
we always start out with this kind of
very good reason by an algebra after a
while we actually start to build them
all of the real things so AI for the
public at large right now is very new
but gradually we'll come to a point
where we where we zero in on what AI
really is rather than just the shallow
analogies that we initially used to try
to understand okay well I'll try it from
a slightly different angle so you know
we were just saying so makes the
argument that it's a biological property
and that's where intentionality and
Consciousness comes from and it's a
requisite but um we'll leave that for
the time being let's let's go the um you
know the photo and the Gary Marcus and
the Chomsky group and they would argue
that creativity is basically this this
notion of or even analogy making for by
extension is this notion of being able
to select from um you know a set which
has an infinite cardinality and the only
and as you know neural networks can't
represent uh infinite sets because
they're finite State automators
therefore they make the move we need to
have this compositionality what do you
say to that well uh there's a lot to
unpack there I think we definitely need
compositionality right if somebody asked
me make a list of houses and things that
absolutely essential for intelligence
compositionality would be one of them
right and this of course is the thing
that people like you know Chomsky and
and Gary and whatnot really care about
right having said that I think first of
all there is no such thing as an
infinite set
right like infinite set is is a Infinity
is a is a useful but extremely
dangerous and confusing mathematical
tool right in the real world there is no
such thing as an infinite anything and
there never will be so I would rephrase
this at well yes creative and almost
anything we can do in AI is selecting
from a very large set not infinite but
very large right and now but now we
don't just select like one full element
at a time we compose it out of pieces
and that's actually where the
intelligence comes in and I don't want
to go too far down the digital physics
route but we did just have Joshua bark
on and um I mean just just in re-clarify
on that would you place yourself in in
that camp that the universe is digital
made of information
uh valid question I certainly think the
universe is finite yeah I I think
whether I mean to you know like Seth
Lloyd says the universe the universe is
a computer right and I think
that is true or false depending on what
you take the word computer to mean right
the universe is not little so if you if
you say that the universe is digital or
is a computer as kind of like an analogy
that lets us understand it better I'm
all for that I don't think the
university is little you know maybe his
way to put this the universe is a
computation
like I don't know what the computer is
or if there is one now the universe is
digital in the sense that deep down at
the most basic level the universe is
made of discrete things okay it's just
like the it from bit the John Wheeler
type hypothesis uh yes
um I mean if you read that paper uh it's
his I mean John really was a brilliant
person again a very you know to get back
to frustrial lasers you know tweet he
was very good at coming up with these
provocative Notions right yeah and the
it for me thing of course is like newly
invoked today and I do so at that level
I do agree that looking at the universe
is being made of information is very
useful and in particular if you want a
grand unified Master algorithm in some
sense the only way that I at least can
see of doing that is by seeing
everything as information so I think and
in fact there's something that I am
working on that looking at everything as
information is a very productive thing
to do yeah but but I the my caution is
that information is one aspect of
everything so I can give you a theory of
everything that's based on information
but it's not truly a theory of
everything it's the theory of one aspect
of everything and I think there's a lot
to be done there but again we shouldn't
forget what we're leaving out when we
focus on that aspect yeah I mean we've
spoken a lot on the show about you know
um uh penrose's View and obviously sales
view that arises from from biology and
and I know if Keith was here he would
argue strongly that he believes in in
continua and therefore we would need in
a hyper computation uh to have this
universe that would be an interesting
discussion to have because I really
don't see where there is physical or any
evidence for continue of any kind the
evidence is always that continue our
useful approximation but always
underlying the continue is a discrete
reality you take a sensor of anything
right you know quantum mechanics is like
the quintessential example of this right
what do we measure at the end it's
always discrete events right like it's
the detect section of a photon by you
know by whatever detector right could be
a molecule of adoption or a CCD or
whatever but it's it's a it's a change
of state it really is a bit
how interesting well how would you
contrast it you know when Stephen
wolfram's got this idea of of um digital
physics and you know maybe and again
unfortunately we have to use arguments
from Behavior you know to kind of say
well we've we've got potentially a um a
graph cellular automata and it creates
this beautiful emergent structure which
is very much like the Universe
um but you know um Scott Aaronson would
make the argument that he's discounting
quantum mechanics I mean what would you
say to that
so I think Steve wolfram's theory is
very interesting and he gets some things
right that a lot of other physicists
don't
in particular that the Universe At Heart
is discrete
so I'm very much with him on that aspect
of his agenda and thank God there's
someone like him and a number of others
you know going that route right they're
the minority in physics but actually I
think if you look at just what has
happened the last 10 years things are
very much moving in this direction and I
think they're going to move more right
now having said that his specific Theory
I think has a lot of shortcomings and I
don't think it's the ultimate Theory or
maybe even the best path to a theory uh
you know to a discretory of the universe
Scott aaronson's critique in that regard
I think misses the point right it's
interesting it's interesting that you
should like pair those two because Steve
wolf from in a way is a physicist who
became a computer scientist and Scott is
the other way around right and I think
you know like I greatly admire both of
them and I'm friends with both of them
I've had many discussions with them I
think you know just to very you know
cruelly caricature things in a way the
problem with Steve is that he has bought
into the computer science assumptions
too much and the problem with with Scott
is that he has bought into the quantum
physics this entrance too much right so
if you really think carefully and
rigorously about quantum mechanics all
that continuous mathematics is there
just to make discrete predictions so the
continuity may be useful it is useful
I'm not arguing against the use of
continuity and infinite in our
mathematics in fact we'd be nowhere if
we didn't have it we just have to
remember that it's an approximation it's
a useful fiction right so quantum
mechanics in no way uh invalidates Steve
will from theories right the problem
however is that he has not entirely you
know ever since seller automata days
right he was always saying like oh you
know the laws of physics will come out
of this seller automata right and people
have these objections and and you know
now he and others have partly answered
some of them but the truth is at the end
of the day he the only way to answer
that objection is to say look here is
how quantum mechanics arises from my
discrete model of the world and I think
this will happen but it better hasn't
happened yet interesting okay we'd love
to get Stephen on the show actually he's
got a he's got a new book out now which
is kind of like expanding on on his
previous work but um okay um I was
having a chat with um uh some alignment
folks yesterday and it's something that
I'm a bit naive to but as I said I've
just read a book um I think it's called
the rationalist's guide to the uh to the
universe and it kind of talks all about
the um the early embryonic stages of
Robin Hansen and Nick Bostrom and elieza
yukowski and the less wrong community
and you know the info hazards and um you
know I don't know if you've heard of
Rocco's basilicus and and all of this
line of thought basically and um yeah so
where to go with this now I I kind of um
put forward that part of my problem uh
with their conception is that it relies
on this rational agent making
trajectories of optimal decisions and
also they um they tend to be
utilitarianism and utilitarianists and
consequentialists and um yeah I just
wondered what's your kind of like high
level take on this
well there's many aspects to this right
I think let me put it this way
I
a rational agent right is an agent that
maximizes a maximizes expected utility
right the definition of rationality is
that it's you know expected utility
maximization right and there is a lot of
contents to this right and you know
people in many fields like economics and
and they and you know AI right they make
good use of it it doesn't answer the
question of what is the utility that
you're maximizing right so if you give
me a 2d function right now if you
maximize it you're rational you can it
can be bound you can be boundedly
rational because you're and indeed
that's this is the interesting and
prevalent case is that you can only
maximize it within balance and you have
to make compromises since this fast and
whatnot but still you're rational if you
don't do that you are irrational right
so rationality is a very you know like
so many mistakes that we make as a
society as individuals would be avoided
if only we were rational in that sense
so at that level I sympathize very much
with that view of the world having said
that there's a huge gaping hole in the
middle of this which is like but what is
your utility function right and and you
know 182 is just like oh that's for you
to decide you know you you tell what me
what you truly function is but but then
you you're you're entitled to say well
like but like my whole problem is that I
want to figure out what my two lead
function should be and and at that point
this whole theory of rationality just
doesn't help you at all the utility
function is an input right so another
question becomes what is your utility
function right and then there's a very
related but as Hume said very different
question which is like what should your
utility function be like should is a
very loaded word here right and then
what what usually happens is things like
this is that our Notions of morality and
so on are trying to impose a should on
you a utility function that you should
have because it serves the utility of
the society
now from the point of view this Society
this is good right but from the point of
view because the society hopefully will
live and prosper if its elements
contribute to its utility not just their
own right but it still doesn't answer
the question so you can you're entitled
to ask so what does answer the question
right and my view on this is that none
of these people you know these people
include Kant and Bentham and you know
Plato on everybody right they you can't
do that right the the the the the so
to me the Supreme reality of Life
Supreme maybe is is a bad word but like
the overarching reality is evolution
right everything we are is created by
Evolution and as somebody famously said
nothing in biology makes sense except in
the light of evolution nothing
immorality makes sense except in light
of evolution not just biological
evolution that's part of it but also
social and cultural Evolution so at the
end of the day the question that you
need to ask yourself is like is which
utility functions are fitter and those
are the ones that will prevail so so
let's let's go there it's very
interesting now um you're known as a
skeptic of collectivist food right I
mean and there's this interesting
dichotomy you're talking about of you
know um monolithic truth but
um the utility function is interesting
as well because in a sense it I mean I
know these folks are consequentialist
but in a sense that's more leaning
towards deontology I did it again
deontology
um you know which is this idea that we
have kind of like a principled approach
to um to morality and I'm skeptical as
well that it's possible to create such a
utility function because it wouldn't
really be parsimonious but how do you
wrestle that that you have a simple
utility function even though you believe
in in diversity of ideas oh no I didn't
say simple
go on crucial point the utility function
could be extremely complex
and in fact the utility function so
first of all there's more than one level
to this
YouTube let's say you believe in
utilitarianism right which I don't but
have you know compared to the others is
probably the least bad right yeah
believing you tell if you believe in
maximizing utility function that in no
way sanctions collectivism
collectivism is one particular strand
that historically came out of that right
and and you know again and Bentham is
responsible for it but it's this notion
that you should have a utility function
in which everybody counts equally
this is now making a choice of utility
function which is different from having
one okay but I think you're saying
something quite interesting as well
which is that at the moment the the
utility is a function of market value
which is very much inspired by Adam
Smith's um Hidden Hand of the market but
but I think your your views against
collectivism is very much against this
idea of a quality of outcome and that's
definitely not what you're no I mean
that's even going beyond that right
equality of outcome is actually
irrational frankly to to we could go
into that but you know you mentioned the
market right then the market is the size
utility again that is a a one way to
decide I mean
there is also a very good approximation
to what you really want so actually all
we have whether it's capitalism or
communism at this point in terms of
utility function are very imperfect
right and that's even saying it
generously and really our job is to try
to come up with something better which I
totally think we can right and by the
way one very Salient question here which
again uh for economists it's very silent
is this the question of like should you
have one utility function overarching
controlling everything even if it's
complex right or should you not right
and and that that I that I think is a
very interesting question right and
there are there are good arguments in
both directions right so let me just
give you one silly example which then I
think also generalizes to other things
does your brain have a singularity
function and I think the answer is no
now you could say from an evolutionary
point of view the overarching utility is
Fitness but then the way that cashes out
in your brain is that your your genes
need con to control this adaptive
machine right in such a way that it
gives you give you give the machine
Freedom right to do things that the
genes by themselves couldn't but at the
same time at the end of the day that
machine has to subserve the propagation
of those genes and the way you do this
right at least the way Evolution seems
to have done it and then I think it
makes a lot of sense is that you don't
just have one utility you have several
ones which correspond to your emotions
and then they fight it out
so I actually think there's this
connection between rationality and the
emotion that people don't make which is
that you know your emotions are really
your utility functions you just have
different ones that cater to different
things right you know fear and anger and
so on and so I think in reality we
actually have multiple utility functions
but because again it gets to this
problem that what we're trying to do is
approximate something that is very
complex and difficult to get at maybe it
is just one but we're better off at
trying to approximate it with 10 or 20
different things and just trying to nail
that one thing that's really interesting
and it is your view then on having this
diversity of utility functions analogous
to your views on the master algorithm
huh it's analogous but you're actually
talking about different dimensions right
you could make a table where on one side
you have all the different utilities and
then on the other side you have the
algorithms and now you can pair off any
any one of them I can say I'm gonna you
know pursue this you know minimize your
fear using symbolism or minimum so any
combination is valid
really really interesting okay and then
um let's get into meritocracy for
example so at the moment we do have the
market system and presumably you think
that some people do genuinely have more
market value than others for sure no and
by the way I think I I'm definitely a
big believer in meritocracy I think
um but what does it mean to you right
very good so let's let's get that down
first right Mary talkers so
our goal is to have a society that that
functions best and provides best for
everybody right and I mean we could
refine even that but let's just take
that for now as our assumption right but
then if that is the case one of our
primary goals maybe even the most
important one is to get everybody to
contribute the most they can
right meritocracy is often seen as like
I'm going to record the people and at
the top is the greatest genius and at
the bottom is the most useless person
and this is wrong right meritocracies in
many dimension thing yeah right the goal
of America talks is to find for
everybody what they're best at doing so
that they can do it maximize everybody's
contribution to society right
and and this is a very complicated
process there isn't a single skill of
intelligence or anything else having
said that it very much is the case that
some people are better for some things
than others right and If you deny that
you are actually in the process of
destroying the society and making it
dysfunctional so the attack I find the
attacks on meritocracy extremely
disturbing right and a lot of them are
you know I've talked with many people
who have those beliefs right and the
number one thing that they say is is
basically boils down to like oh
meritocracy isn't perfect so we should
junk it something be not being perfect
has never been a reason to junk it it's
a reason to improve it so there's a lot
of room to improve in meritocracy but if
you throw it away you are destroying
Society well I mean this this
um you can trace this back to our
argument about utility but
um the thing is though if we had
um a value function which represented
actual Market contributions or even
societal contributions that would be one
thing but would you agree that that we
have a of um game playing at the moment
so utility is based on playing the
success game or the dominance game or
The Virtue game as will store said in
this book so we've got these kind of
emerging games and it's like it's not
really representing utility well
absolutely so
so far we've been talking about utility
right but what happens in the real world
is that there are multiple agents each
with their own different utility and at
this point what you have is Game Theory
right game theory is just what you have
when there's not a single optimization
going on but multiple optimizations
which are partly contradictory maybe
partly not so the best way to understand
everything that we've been talking about
including society and evolution and even
what happens inside your brain is as a
big game
a much bigger and more complex game than
game theorists and economists and so on
and evolutionary biologists might
prominently have been able to handle in
the past but I think they are very much
in the right track and we can understand
a lot of this phenomena that you're
referring to as they are against being
played by people that have certain
utilities right and now you are going to
impose your you know like and it's a
game right I don't you don't know who's
going to win until you actually do the
linear program and and figure out how
this is gonna you know and of course
games are you know in reality you know
most games are not single round games
right they they're continuing games
right so things get very very
interesting but this I think is the most
productive way to look at all of this
okay good good but but then some some
might say that this is a a platonic way
of looking at the world and the world is
actually much more complicated than that
and again we're kind of Fooled by
Randomness because we're
anthropomorphizing the world and we're
kind of framing it as a game it might be
much more complicated than that
um I've already said this a couple of
times but you know the concept of power
for example did when Napoleon said I
want the men to March into this come
into this country is it just a simple
kind of chain of command that goes down
no it's not it's so much more
complicated than that well yes but
that's I'm actually I'm not even sure
what you mean by when you say it's much
more complicated than a game again when
I say a game
maybe what comes to your mind is
something simple like in a prisoner's
dilemma two two players two moves it's a
game with you know with a vast number of
players each with a vast number of moves
interesting but but I think this gets to
the core of what the rationalists talk
about that they have these thought
experiments they talk about prisoners
dilemma they have that I forget the name
of that game where there's the two boxes
and you have to choose the the box I
forget that but I guess what I'm saying
is is that if you do have this
rationalist conception of the world and
think about it in terms of game of Game
Theory just like the um the symbolists
do and the people who handcraft
cognitive architectures do even with
causality for example we create these
variables it's all anthropomorphic well
um I would not so let me let me put it
this way right you can model almost
anything
can is an important word here you can
model almost anything in the world in
any domain from physics to psychology to
socio genetic as optimizing a function
whether you should is a debatable
question but you can right but now what
really happened is that there are many
different optimizations going on at the
same time all the way from maximizing
entropy to me deciding what I have for
lunch today and now what you have is all
of these interlocking optimizations and
that's what I'm calling Game Theory
right one of those optimizations is I'm
Napoleon I want to conquer Russia you're
the desire of Russia you don't want to
be conquered right and then we play a
very complicated game which includes
other agents like your soldiers which
maybe you know I a French soldier you
know want to conquer Russia but I also
want to stay alive whereas an opponent
really couldn't care less whether I in
particular still have or not as long as
he conquers Russia in the end so this
very complex game I think is what goes
on I don't think framing things in this
way is anthropomorphizing them in fact I
think this is our best hope to not enter
one more fights things although at the
end of the day I think you can look at
almost anything and see a ghost of enter
formatization there but if there's a
less anthropomorphic way to look at the
universe than through this lens I'd be
interested to see what it is well the
only reason I'm saying this is first of
all I want to play Devil's Advocate a
little bit and um we even spoke about
the Blind Men and the Elephant a little
while ago and
um I'm sure folks on the left as they
did they criticized Ayan ran for example
and they said that she had this very
transactional way of you know viewing
the world as this kind of Nash
equilibrium of of self-interested actors
and are we guilty of doing that are we
kind of like cutting off many aspects of
the truth by doing this I guess that's
what I'm saying so we are always cutting
off some aspect of the truth when we
look at anything in any way right which
is not a reason to to look at nothing in
no way right so I think this is a very
productive way to look at things but not
the only one it doesn't exhaust what
there is to be said but I personally
feel like it's the one where the most
progress can come from interesting now
that's sort of like iron Randy and
simplification of the world I the the
looking at things this way does not
imply oversimplifying them on the
contrary I would actually say it gives
us a handle on how to go into the
complexity and not get lost and and not
devolve into like platitudes or
oversimplifying ideologies right the
fact that there's a mathematical
component to this is very important
right mathematics when you can apply it
gives you a very solid handle on things
we are now at the point where we can
handle a lot of things mathematically
slash computationally that we couldn't
before so when Von Neumann invented Game
Theory right he said this is the future
of the social sciences and so far it
hasn't been but I think we're actually
now at the point where partly because we
have the data right we actually can now
usefully apply this point of view in a
way that we couldn't before how far it
takes us we'll see it's not the only
possible way to look at things but I do
think it's probably the most productive
at this point interesting okay so coming
back to this rationalist school of
thought um one thing that I'm interested
in is is um morality but let's let's go
one step at a time so I think Bostrom
came up with this idea of instrumental
convergence which is this notion that in
the pursuit of doing a particular task
the um the intelligence system might
actually
um potentially kill everyone on on the
planet or do adjacent type and this is
this is where the interesting thing
comes from so one task uh but adjacent
multitask ability and a you know like
potential intelligence and so on so um
there was an example of a cauldron so
you know um you you've got someone
filling up a cauldron and in the pursuit
of filling up The Cauldron to just the
right level they might kill the person
who looks after the The Cauldron room
just to so so that the agent could do it
more efficiently
um are you are you cynical about that or
what do you think
no I'm not cynical about that but let me
put it this way
I don't lose any sleep worrying about
the you know paper clip Factory that's
going to take over the world right I
think you have to take that as a
philosopher's thought experiment right
uh you know the philosopher being Nick
in this case right I think there's a
there's a real danger that there's
putting its finger on but it's not but
it's also
um mistaking reality for something else
so let's look at both parts of that
right the real danger is that
um if you give an AI a a a an
oversimplified a hugely oversimplified
objective function and at the same time
a very large amount of power bad things
will happen and we need to worry about
that right so and by the way this is
already a problem today in in many maybe
more modest ways but but also more
relevant frankly right and so what do
you do right first of all is the utility
function needs to be as rich and as
complex and as subtle as the people that
is trying to serve right so you as long
as what you have to take a really World
example today social media who's
you know are all designed to just
maximize engagement
right you have an enormous amount of AI
at the service of Maxi matching
engagement it's a very I understand why
companies do it and partly they have the
right to we can get into that but the
point is the the consequence it's
ignoring too many things right so one
line of defense against is like you have
to enrich utility function until it's
like a bet and then is it this is an
open-ended problem right we're not we're
never going to have the final utility
function it's something that the AIS
have to be continued you know AIS I
think Stuart Russell said this and I
agree like they should spend half their
time figuring out what the utility
function is and then the other half
maximizing it whereas today it's like I
wrote down my activity function in one
line and now I spend this enormous
amount of power maximizing it so that's
one line the other line or like one
other line is you have to put
constraints on the machine hard
constraints you can in the pursuit of
the circular function you can think of
it as like you know terms with infinite
weight in digital function you can't go
outside this and then the other one is
the single biggest reason why sort of
like this paper clip experiment is silly
is that you know along with that paper
clip factor in the world they're going
to be a million other AIS You Know Each
of which is doing the same thing so none
of them is ever going to acquire the
power to cause that damage unless it's
doing something very different from just
trying to make paper clips so at some
level that example is extremely
unrealistic and leads us down the wrong
track right loads of places to go there
but um first of all I think you do
believe in AI alignment then because
you're saying exactly the same as what
they do which is that we need to have a
utility function that represents the the
richness of The Human Condition so
that's the first thing so so essentially
you're all on board of alignment well I
believe in AI alignment in one sense of
it many different things get go under
that umbrella alignment right I think in
the near term thinking of things into I
mean if a light let me put it this way
if AI alignment is just trying to have a
really accurate utility function and
then yes and then the machines are
optimizing that function absolutely
right yeah and and in the near term I
think talking about AI alignment is a
little I mean the problem that I have
with the concept of alignment is that it
goes far beyond that it tends to see AIS
as these independent agents that we have
to align their goals to ours right yeah
and and and if that just cashes out as
like you know here's the utility
function that's fine but the problem is
AIS are not independent agents AIS are
our tools well just to push back on that
a little bit because I always had that
conception of these folks I thought I
was arguing against people who believed
in a pure monolithic intelligence and
then they um a lot of them are
transhumanist actually and they say that
they they want to
um you know ensure human flourishing
through the kind of the use of of AIS in
tandem almost as a kind of extended mind
from from David Chalmers and but but
then um I really wanted to get into
their fears of recursive of
self-improving intelligence and super
intelligence because when you do have
this kind of heterogeneous approach to
humans and and machines there are going
to be bottlenecks everywhere now I I
like to think of it a bit like the
market efficiency hypothesis which is
that you reach an equilibria where um
you know the the individual actors in
The Market become more efficient will
become more efficient programmers
because we're using codecs but we will
reach a limit surely
well um to touch on transhumanism for
just a second right because I do agree
with you kind of at least sociologically
a lot of that crowd is the same right
let me put it this way right then I'm
sure this is a controversial statement
but maybe in the long run the ass should
take over the world
why are we so arrogant that we think
whatever the AI is it should always be
there to serve us you know we are a step
if you take the Long View of this right
we're stepping Evolution right we're
amazing maybe I'm a human chauvinist but
I do think we are amazing but we're not
the last word
right so you know the other day I
tweeted something that you know is you
know maybe provocative but it's like uh
um I think in campsites which is I say
that the killer app of humans is
producing AI
maybe our role in evolution is that
we're going to produce an AI right that
is you know the next level of whatever
you like Consciousness intelligence
etc etc right and so the notion that in
the very long term the eyes that should
still be there to subserve us by this
point of view is actually silly right
right but okay so I mean a lot a lot of
um folks let's say the ethics folks
would find it horrifying that and I was
speaking to Irena actually yesterday and
she she said something a little bit
tongue-in-cheek which is that we should
do sorry uh Arena from Montreal Mila um
right oh yeah I know her yeah yeah yeah
we were classmates at UC River amazing
yeah I I really love her but um no she
was kind of joking that we should almost
align human values to the to the AGI
values but but well that that I find
alarming well I think she was saying it
tongue-in-chees I'm Not Alone by a lot
of things but yeah but but what do you
what do you think about this um uh this
ethical concern that if that if it is
the case that you believe that you know
we're just one wrong on the ladder and
you know transhumanism is more AI than
it is human
um people would find that horrifying
well uh I I understand why people would
find that horrifying and I mean again we
have to distinguish the shorts from the
meaning from the long term when I say
something like this I'm talking about
the very long term right trying to make
human subservients subservient to AI
today is a horrifying idea right now I
think the reason a lot of people are
horrified with this idea period right is
natural but in my view naive is just
they are uh seeing humans as the end
goal
okay if humans are the end goal then the
idea that they should be subservant to
developing the the next level of AI is
horrifying if you have a moral system
where humans are the the the the be-all
and end-all then all this is horrifying
but again if you take the Long View of
evolution
humans are not the be-all and then
though okay I mean eventually this might
take us to the effect of altruism
discussion but um I I think as we were
saying Sam Harris recently had a podcast
talking about the FTX disaster and he
was kind of making the argument that
we're all consequentialists even even if
we don't realize it but there are
different degrees of consequentialism
and I think a lot of the um the ethics
Folks at the moment they really really
don't like what's going on with with
long-termism and it's because there's
this slippery slope of the kind of
horizon of consequentialism so with Nick
Bostrom you know he came up with this
number that there could be simulated
humans you know living on other planets
in the future it's a very big number I
think it's like you know it's got a lot
of zeros on it and watch them what's to
stop us from just making the argument
and what's the stock AI is from making
the argument that those simulated lives
have more value than our lives
okay there's a lot to unpack there
um so but let's take this one step at a
time
I very much by the idea of effective
altruism on principle right I think that
is the way to go about a lot of things I
think in some ways uh if you are not an
effective altruist may be unconsciously
you are being irrational or maybe evil
right if you believe in altruism I mean
like think about both parts of that
right if altruism is good then then
let's say we take that right and then
why should we why should we be in favor
of ineffective altruism right if you
wanna if you're an altruist if you want
the good of other people you should try
to do the best you can right and so for
example I very much by the notion that
like you want to you know make the most
money you can so then you can give away
that money as opposed to volunteering at
the soup kitchen volunteering at the
soup kitchen for say someone with a PhD
machine learning is an ineffective form
of altruism now having said that I think
the focus on the long term
has been in many ways I mean certainly
the long term is important right but but
the problem with the whole effect of
altruism movement is that it got overly
focused on that and we can talk about
why and then even even and then a
further mistake is that it got overly
focused on this supposedly existential
dangers that are much less of a big deal
than people think like AI
so between effective altruism and
fixating on AI is an extensional danger
lies a huge golf I'm for Effective
altruism I think you know the long long
term you know there's ins and outs there
right and then this focus on like these
existential dangers is is very
problematic you know for example you
know to get back to the you know
Bostonian notion of like all these Minds
that matter more than us and whatnot
there is a basic idea right that like
any Economist knows which is that you
have to Discount the future and the
question is well your is what your
discount rate is right and if your
discount rate is high right those those
minds matter not at all and now why do
you have that discount rate the primary
reason is that there's uncertainty about
the future right I have to weigh the the
certain benefit of helping you today
with the increasingly hypothetical
benefit of helping your mind there's
less and less likely to exist in the
future so in many of those cases the
present and the short term do win okay
but a couple of things to contrast that
so a lot of effective altruism is this
idea that we're born with faulty
programming right so we
um we have these views you know like we
have this concept of of moral um value
and it gets discounted in space and time
right so we need ways of overcoming our
programming but you were saying that we
we should be and thinking about this but
contrast that with your um you know with
your statement about Ayan Rand earlier
right so Ayan Rand was very very
transactional because I think the um the
folks that criticize this movement um
are suspicious that we are actually
being a bit more like I am Rand
um but with the guys of of altruism and
I think that and they they think of the
FTX disaster as being kind of like
evidence of that
a lot of different points there the FDX
disaster actually has nothing whatsoever
to do with any of this right Sandman
feed was one guy or is one guy funny
that I use the past tense he's one guy
who believed in effective altruism good
for him right he was I mean the whole
FTS thing was also obviously I mean yeah
we could get into that but the point is
you you should not I understand why
people's image of effective altruism
would be tainted by what happened with
Sam backmanfield but really it shouldn't
be right you know an idea is not
responsible for the you know mistakes
that its Believers make in in in
unrelated domains point one point two
transactionalism there is nothing in
what I've said whatsoever that implies
transactionalism in fact the opposite
right I think relationalism is is
actually the the key concept and part of
this is that uh games are not one shot
your games are played in a repeatedly
and famously for example if you play
things like prisoners limit what not
repeated like like you know cooperate
defect and whatnot as soon as you start
bringing in these other things like that
make things more realistic you actually
start to get behavior that is much more
you know what's the way to put it
rational in some ways and human and
whatnot right another one is that
traditional economics which I think
einron was influenced by viewed and
still views the world as linear
but the world is non-linear once you
start seeing the world is non-linear all
of these things really change you know
the face of them changes right so I
think we have to look at all these
Concepts in this view right and and we
want to focus on the long so
I so I so to get to go back to your
first point right we are born with
faulty programming part of our and
that's what if you know effective
alteration is there to overcome right
part of our faulty programming is that
our discount rate is too high
because we evolved in a world where your
time Horizon was very short
the fact that it's too high doesn't mean
that we should make it zero
and care only about the future but what
would you know the ethics folks who um
advocate for gatekeeping and paternalism
um couldn't you just say that they're
doing the same thing
well you should ask them right but
wouldn't they wouldn't they lead by
saying our programming is 14 and
therefore you know we we need to no I
mean look uh we can so part one we can
debate whether our programming is faulty
or not and why and so to just start by
touching on that our programming is
faulty so our programming is not faulty
in the sense that we evolved for a
particular set of conditions right and
that Evolution may not be complete or
optimal etc etc but roughly speaking we
are not faulting that sense the reason
because evolution is doing its job right
we have all those impulses for a reason
right now the problem is that we unlike
any other species we actually have
actually succeeded in creating a world
that is better for us but at the same
time and this is the problem we are
actually now adapted to a different
world from the one that we live in so
the faulty program just comes from the
fact that we evolved for one set of
conditions for example among many other
examples where your time Horizon was
very short and now we live in a very
different world and so our job as
rational people that's what our rational
minds are for among other things is to
now adapt ourselves to the world that we
really are in so that we do things that
are rational in the world that we're in
right so now the fact that our
programming is faulty there's not in
does not say anything about what are the
thoughts on how you fix them and what
these people have I think is first of
all the wrong notion of what our faults
are and then on top of that the wrong
notion of how to fix them
okay now I want to get into the utility
function again now again one of the
things that makes me skeptical is is
this notion of immutability both of of
what we're doing and in the case of of
what we've been speaking about with uh
utilitarianism what the utility function
is now you were kind of hinting to
something interesting before which is
that that it might be diverse and it
might also be self-updating but I'm
constantly asking myself the question
how does that work and who gets to say
well so very much I think it's complex
and it should be self-updating right
we're never going to final itself
if you buy this notion that the ultimate
Arbiter is evolution then utility
functions are subject to evolution
right so you you think about it or you
can't think of should
wrong world you you can't think about
this and it's useful to think about this
in the following ways to a first
approximation the number one entity
that's evolving is utility functions
what you have in the world at any point
is a population of utility functions
right yeah and now they combine they
evolve you have next Generation two
functions and then and then there's also
how the utility function gets optimized
there is also subject to Evolution right
and now how the tool function is
optimized changes a lot faster and
there's a lot more complex than the
utility function itself which is the
point right so at a certain time Horizon
it's reasonable to approximate utilities
as being fixed like for example the
utilities that are encoded in your brain
are fixed by your genes right so in the
context of our present you know human
moment and effective altimism or not it
makes perfect sense to think of utility
is fixed but it is evolving and not just
on you know Eon time skills but by by
the generation right you know things
evolve by the generation okay but it's
still relatively Glacier and I I I take
your point that there's a kind of
Divergence between the world we live in
and the programming that we've got but
then okay let's imagine that we create a
new population and I guess what I'm
saying is is that you think that the
utility function should emerge and
evolve but I would argue for some kind
of morphogenetic engineering where it's
a kind of hybrid between something which
is emerging but something which we can
nudge oh I mean um I'm glad you brought
that up
nudging is a form of emergence you
yourself are emergent and the things
that you do are emergent as well
everything is emergent right utilities
are emergent maybe the laws of physics
aren't emerging some people will say
even those are right like you know we
live in a universe with this constants
because blah blah blah right so but to
First approximation every single thing
that we've been talking about is
emergent we make a distinction between
emergent and designed because that is
anthrophomorphic right is this things
that we do are not emergent actually no
when you touch something that is an
emergent Behavior right we are emergent
as well right so everything that is
human you know so here's a very good way
I think to think about a lot of things
which I first saw you know in in Richard
Dawkins which is although he really
didn't go into this and I wish it had
like this notion of the extended
phenotype right technology is our
extended phenotype so all these things
that we do right all these things that
we build including as and whatnot they
are extensions of our phenotype so if
you take the Long View All of You Know
Technologies by all is the continuation
of biology by another means so when you
make this distinction between emergent
and non-emergent and top down and bottom
up it's all emergent interesting well
when we recently did a show on emergence
and it's a topic of interest to me
personally and there's there's weak
emergence and strong emergence and
there's you know like the view of weak
emergence so there's some you know
surprising macroscopic phenomena maybe
something which transiently emerges and
Wolfram would add in the whole um you
know computational irreducibility angle
and then with the strong emergence
Chalmers would say it's something which
is paradigmatically surprising it's
something which is not deducible for
many fundamental truths and the lower
level domain but um I just wondered like
how do you think about emergence well I
think there is a very the distinction
between weak and strong emission is a
very useful one right right and and now
actually phrase it in slightly different
terms which is starting from physics
right I think
most physicists and scientists believe
in Weak emergence could I add the Sabine
hosenfelda had a paper and she frames it
with this idea of the resolution of um
physical theories so like like a lower
resolution theory is weakly emerging
from a high resolution well exactly and
you know like I like Sabine but this is
not her idea right this far predates all
of us here right yeah and again it's
it's a very interesting history and a
very important concept now so my point
was that I think few people have a
quarrel with the notion of weak
emergence in the sense that you know I
can give you a theory of everything in
the form of whatever String Theory let's
take a candidate right but no String
Theory claims that that's a theory of
everything in a sense that like now to
study biology psychology sociology
should just study String Theory No One
Believes that right there's actually
interesting things to be said there but
but let's not let's look at let's look
on there for a second right there are
these levels that uh emerge weekly in
the sense that they are determined by
the lower levels they're just so much
more complex that you're better off
focusing on the menu now there's this
other notion system is the really
interesting one which is that there is
there are phenomena that are at the
higher levels that are just not
reducible to the lower levels yeah right
it's a true emergent is in some sense is
someone who believes the latter and now
you can ask the question like do you
believe in that or not right and I think
um
to give the very short answer first is
that ultimately there is probably no way
of knowing
but pragmatically you're actually
probably better off treating the world
as if it has strong emergence and now
strong emotions actually a very strong
segment to make is to say and by the way
going down to the lowest levels to make
things very clear you don't need to
think about biology of society or
Consciousness or anything condensed
matter physics right the particle
physicists tend to believe that what
they do is what everything reduces to
you talk to the condensed metaphysicists
this was actually an interesting
discussion that I had with Scott you
know Aaronson because like he was very
much on this we're both computer
scientists but he was very much on the
side of the particle physicists on the
very much on the side of the condensed
metaphysicists what they will tell you
over and over again they see is things
that you cannot explain using quantum
mechanics and now people say like oh but
you can always explain things in quantum
mechanics you just haven't done the
calculations but the point is precise
that you can't do the calculations right
the calculations are chaotic yeah I have
a theory I can come up with 500 the
theories of these phenomena and
semiconductors and whatnot and like I
never actually get to test them because
the computations diverge before I get to
test them so for all intents and
purposes it is strong emergence whether
truly that came from below is
unanswerable because you can't compute
the predictions we Spike about that so
and I think Keith would call that
semi-strong emergence which is like you
know whether it's computationally
reachable from from the the lower
resolution to the top from the high
resolution to the lower resolution
um but no um um Sabine in her paper a
case for strong emergence she was
talking about singularities as being a
really good example of what might be
strong emergence and the philosopher
Mark Bedell um I think said that strong
emergencies is ridiculous it's basically
an affront on physicalism
well certainly a you know strong
emerging in physicalism or let's just
call it reductionism reductionism yeah
strong emergence and reductionism are
incompatible yeah yeah and and and we
scientists tend to be reductionists yeah
right now now you like and at some level
I'm both a reductionist and someone who
is willing to believe in strong
emergence again I don't believe in
strong emergence I just don't see a way
to disprove it right and where the semi
and like you know if there's an
empirical way to distinguish semi-strong
from strong emissions I'd be very
interested to know what it is but now I
think the thing that is very important
that a lot of people including a lot of
physicists and scientists don't see is
that we have this hypothesis that
everything can be reduced to the laws of
physics as we know it we should not
forget that it's just a hypothesis and
it's a hypothesis that again counter to
a lot of people say is very very very
very far from established and usually
people say like oh but you know look at
all the successes of the laws of physics
and blah blah and then I say like you
know putting on my machine learning hat
the sample that you've used to validate
the laws of physics is extraordinarily
biased in the direction of simple
systems
okay so you can't make this claim of if
the data was IID I could say which with
great confidence these laws apply
universally but I haven't done it it's
more like I've just landed in a new
continent and I sealed up all the rivers
and I say I know what this continent
looks like you've never climbed the
mountains you've never gone in the
jungle so like this motion that there
was a physics capture everything about
daily life we just don't know how
exactly maybe it's true but it could
also equally well be completely false
brilliant well you gave a bit of a hint
to this earlier actually because you
used the word relationalism right which
which is basically the relationalism it
should be you know shortened to religion
relationalism
um but uh yeah I think uh Rosen is a
great advocate of this and he has a
whole kind of um uh category Theory
calculus for for describing uh living
assistance and and also we spoke to uh
Bob [ __ ] the quantum um uh physics
Professor from Cambridge and he was
talking about this concept of Cartesian
togetherness which is another categorial
framework but I just wondered like you
know does that inform your your view
well relationalism at least in one you
know way of defining the term very much
informs my view right and and one way to
come at this is to say the world is not
made of independent entities and so
let's just start with machine learning
which is a very concrete way to look at
this a very large part maybe even the
largest part of my research in the last
20 years has been to do away with the
Assumption of IID data right that the
world is made of independent entities in
particular societies made of independent
agents etc etc right now we make this
assumption both as human beings you know
to some extent and certainly very much
so in science because it makes life
easier
the math is way way easier when you
assume Independence but it's a blatantly
false assumption right unfortunately a
lot of for example economics prominently
has embedded in it this notion that the
world is a bunch of independent agents
and it just doesn't work like that and
moreover it's a distinction that is full
of consequences a society and economy is
a network of agents and almost all the
action is in their interactions until
you really start taking that seriously
you really don't understand the world
again I have no call with classic
economics as a first approximation it's
exactly what it should be right but then
and by the way you should also not just
throw it away and say like oh this is
garbage like some people say you have to
go the next stage actually now we have
the mathematical and computational tools
to do and understand it as being a
system of interacting agents and all of
the questions that we are talking about
including you know in
um you know in evolution even in physics
right you know a piece of condensed
matter is a network of interacting spins
etc etc you name it so the relations are
at the heart of it and moreover like as
I said a lot of my work is we now have
the representations the learning
inference algorithms to handle things
that are big puzzles of relations and
the whole world is better understood in
those terms and we just need people to
catch up with that you know once you do
that you get into things that can easily
be computationally intractable and so on
and so forth but there's a lot of things
that we can do there and a lot more that
we'll do so at this level I think
relationalism is really should be a
Cornerstone of our understanding of the
world in a way that it hasn't been in
the past okay and which existing
complexity sign Springs to mind but I
mean which existing
um techniques and areas can folks look
into to to take that on board well you
know Markov logic which is what I
developed for this purpose essentially
and I and I do think you know you know
this is my talking about my works it
should naturally be suspicious but I
think it's the best that we have and and
I think by a wide measure compared to
anything else that we have so far okay
and can you sketch it out yeah so uh
this to sketch it out in the simplest
terms right we want to combine all the
all the traditional goodies that we had
from assuming the world is IID with the
power to model you know relationships
there are themselves potentially very
complicated the way we do that in Markov
logic is there's the logical part we
actually do not need to solve a new the
problem of how to represent and do
inference with relations we have first
ordered the logic for that first order
logic is the language of relations
that's actually the term that is used
right and how the relations the
predicate sometimes they're called
predicates but let's just call them
relations right we have a formal
language to talk about relations and by
the way essentially all of computer
science can be reduced to that you give
me your favorite you know whatever
knowledge representation data structure
and etc etc and I can I anybody who
knows can immediately say how to do that
in logic so that's one part the other
part is the statistical you know machine
learning probabilistic aspect the world
right and then again going all the way
back to physics right all of these
things that we deal with are essentially
special cases of what are variously
called Markov networks which is where
the name Markov comes from or graphical
models or log linear models gives
distributions boltzmann machines like
right all of these things are
essentially the same right that whole
neck of the woods is captured by
markovnowers let's call them that and
markovlogic is combining Markov networks
with first our logic in a single
language which you can now do everything
with okay okay so just just to like um
push back a tiny bit so
um in the past we've tried to create
um let's say things like psych which is
a knowledge representation of the world
folks like Montague have tried to do
semantics using first order logic to set
some you know varying degrees of of
success and then we have the grounding
problem we were just talking before
about uh you know like even so said this
that you have kind of um epistemic um
objectivity and subjectivity and some
things are Observer relative like even
economics is Observer relative so um
with this kind of formalism how would
that work not so very good the problem
with or the main problem with a lot of
these things that that you mentioned
like you know certain types of semantics
and whatnot that are based essentially
on first order logic right is that
they're too brittle yeah in fact the
problem with symbolic AI is that it's
too brittle yeah and this is exactly
what markovlogic fixes it fixes it by
making it statistical when I give you a
logical statement now I'm no longer for
example simple logical statement uh you
know a smoking causes cancer right in
English this is a valid statement
smoking does cause cancer but actually
once you translate it to Logic for every
X smokes of X implies cancer of X it's
false because some smokers don't get
cancer right what this really was meant
to be along is a statistical statement
that says smokers are more likely to get
cancer
so so the way we overcome a lot of those
problems is precisely that we take all
of this logic which again the language
exists we don't have to change it we can
but we don't have to and we make it
statistical as a result of which it's no
longer brittle or at least now it's only
as brutal as machine learning and
graphical Muslim or not it's not as
brittle as you know traditional symbolic
AI okay and so we're speaking to a lot
of gofi people and I mean Wally subur
example he's a rationalist and what's
interesting about the rationalists is
they they hate any form of uncertainty
right right they think in absolute
binaries you either know it or you no I
mean let me push back on that there's
this again you need to distinguish you
know a general field or idea from its
subtypes right yeah there is a type of
rationalist that hits uncertainty big
mistake big big mistake there's a type
of rationalist that you know uncertainty
is what they they you know like
and uncertainty calculus is a type of
rationalism and some of the best you
know AI philosophy Etc is just that so
there is no incompatibility at all
between rationalism and uncertainty in
fact if if rationalism if being rational
is maximizing the expected utility
notice the expected in there right you
cannot be rational if you ignore the
uncertainty interesting okay but then um
what about the the resolution of
modeling I mean smoke smoking is a
really good one so us humans we
entrepromorphize things we understand
the world in macroscopic terms using
macroscopic ideas that we understand and
that kind of leads to a certain type of
modeling and that modeling presumably
would be represented at that resolution
and you know using this formalism yeah
well sure and what's the question well
it seemed again like I'm I'm intuitively
suspicious that we were just saying the
world is a complex place and with a lot
of causal modeling for example a lot of
the art is understanding what is
relevant and what is not relevant what
is relevant might just be kind of you
know relevant to us no what is relevant
is what is relevant relative to your
utility function
okay again it gets back to that
precisely
the whole problem is that the world is
infinitely complex and we have only
finite computational resources whether
it's in our brains or our computers or
whatever right so now what do you do
right you are forced to oversimplify the
world not just simplify but oversimplify
right but not the whole art that's
actually a good word to use even if it's
done with computers is how do you not
only simply oversimplify as little as
you can but pick out the simplifications
that are least harmful to your objective
by the way the art of the physicist
physicist will tell you is precisely
doing this right physicists are very
good at deciding what to simplify and in
fact almost I think at some level almost
any good scientists this is what they do
right so and now how do I decide what
and how to simplify is by relevance to
my utility function right I want to
ignore parts of the world that do not
affect my two-way function number one
right and for example the notion of
conditional Independence which is the
foundation of graphical models that's
what the whole idea is is like once I
know these things I don't have to know
about those others thank God right okay
but if Ken Stanley was here he says that
the great thing about evolution is it's
Divergent it's not um convergent it's
discovering new information and My worry
is is with a system like this with any
form of anthropomorphic design would
inevitably become convergent and it
might look like
um all those things over there that
we're ignoring don't matter but actually
they might really matter if they got
introduced into well I wouldn't say that
maximizing expected to lose
anthropomorphic right in fact it's one
of the least and I think maybe there's
some degree of anthropomorphism is
almost anything we do and you know the
progress of science is becoming less and
less anthropomorphic and we should keep
pushing on that but I would say that
maximizing expected utility is one of
the least anthropomorphic things we can
do well this this is actually a really
interesting point because one one of the
key tenets of the rest this movement and
their conception of intelligence because
you know all of the other um definitions
of intelligence are anthropomorphic so
you know there's based on Behavior
capability AI a principle
um uh function is a big one you know
from from norweg and this this is this
is the the principle-based AI which is
um just making rational uh moves so
why why is there such a push to be as
um you know to be as as um uh the least
amount anthropomorphic well uh the push
is not to be at least in my view being
less anthropomorphic is not a goal
because that's not the goal the goal is
to be as accurate and complete as we can
in modeling the world right we're just
trying to understand the world better
right for whatever purpose maybe for its
own sake maybe for the purpose of the
utility and evolution and so on right
but that's the goal the problem is that
and this has been the problem since day
one right they're one of humanity is
that because we anthropomorphize the
world that gets in the way of
understanding how it really works right
if I say the wind there's some God
blowing right I understand right that's
all they could think of but it's a big
obstacle to understanding what the wind
really is like there's a pressure
difference
etc etc right and we've done away with a
lot of anthropomorphism by the way one
of the problems that we're always having
is that it's always pushing back right
you know there's always you know again
intuitively we have a very strong
tendency to enter more messages like as
much as science broadly construct is a
great Victory it's always in danger from
this right but even within science we've
gone to from doing away with the obvious
forms of enter for missing and
trophomorphism to having many things
that are still there that are less
obviously anthropomorphic but still are
right but if there's something in
tropomorphic that's actually is accurate
then more power to it interesting yeah
and then I guess we have so many
cognitive priors right in in our in our
brains that give us a kind of attention
which has it we're just completely
anthropocentric well
very good so those priors and maybe a
better term is heuristics right our
brains are full of heuristics that
Evolution put there for a good reason
because those heuristics work right but
they are heuristics so they have failure
modes right and we need to understand
what is that those heuristics really are
getting at so that we also that so that
we use them when they're good but then
when they're not good we use something
else
brilliant brilliant so Pedro we're here
at neurops this week and um could you
just like sketch out some of the some of
the things you've seen and I also know
that you're a huge fan in um uh that
there's a newer symbolic algorithm that
you want to tell us about so let's let's
hear it so I uh indeed I've been
enjoying uh Europe's this week one of
the big things in AI in the last several
years has been your symbolic AI uh which
you probably would not surprised by the
fact that I very much believe in so and
I believe this since I was a grad
student and the whole idea of nursing
body care was something that nobody was
interested in right and now suddenly
everybody's which I think is a good
development and this is the idea that if
we really want to solve AI by some
definite if we want to get to like human
level intelligence etc etc we need to
have both
uh you know like for example uh deep
learning is not enough right there are
symbolic reasoning capabilities that we
have and that are essential yeah and and
we need to get them and I think you know
intelligent connection is like I don't
know Joshua binjo you know they don't
disagree with this but but but one way
to look at this and say we're just going
to realize those you know capabilities
using purely connectionist means right
and what I see happening in that
direction unfortunately is a lot of
Reinventing the wheel so I do think you
know symbolically I got wedged for some
reasons including brittleness uh and you
know and we have learned from that at
the same time they did discover and
understand a lot of things that are
extremely relevant so it's just not good
science to ignore it so I'm working on
an approach to combine uh you know
symbolic AI with uh with deep learning
again this is a popular exercise these
days there are many interesting
approaches out there as much as I
sympathize with them I think they're all
very far from solving the problem they
are over complicated and not powerful
enough okay so you know I've been
working on an approach called tensor
logic that I do believe is as simple as
it can be and and as general as as it
can or needs to be and and this you know
it it really is a deep unification of
the two things in the sense that it's
not just that you combine them using you
know a neural model that causes symbolic
one or vice versa which is a lot of what
these things that you have today do and
a lot of the things that like oh this
system is neurosymbolic which it is it's
like you know alphago is near symbolic
because some of what it does is symbolic
but I'm talking about something much
deeper which is once you start doing AI
learning inference representation
intensive logic there's just no
distinction between symbolic and and
neural at all anymore
can you explain that so um tensor logic
I'm just inferring from that that the
the primary representation or substrate
is is a continuous Vector space is that
right are you encoding discrete
information into the vector space so
it's a vector space yeah right in fact
this the original term that we had for
this was Vector space logic but then we
changed it to tensor logic because it's
much more appropriate but it's it's
Vector space in the abstract algebra
sense of vector space not in the
traditional you know vectors of numbers
uh but but anyway so uh um
as the name implies right tensor logic
is a combination or unification of
tensor algebra on the one hand and logic
programming on the other so is it
similar because Bob Kovac had a similar
idea using like tensor outer products
is it that kind of it's related but I
think it goes well beyond okay and the
basic idea is actually pretty simple and
it's just the following right without
going into too much you know technical
uh detail
all of deep learning can be done using
tensor algebra yeah uh you know plus
Universe non-linearities right so we got
the tensor Ultra to do that all the
symbolic AI can be done using logic
programming and moreover it has been
done using logic program so if you can
unify these two things this part of the
job is done right and as it turns out
you can unify them shockingly easily
because a tensor and they so tensor
algebra is operating on tensors uh you
know inductive logic so logic
programming and then for Learning and
that's the logic program and symbolic AI
they are all operating on relation yeah
right so what is the relationship
between the tensor and the relation
right a relation is just this and
efficiently represented sparse Boolean
tensor so at this point we actually know
that the foundation of these two things
is actually the same if your tensor is
is Boolean and is very sparse now I'm
better off representing it with a
relation but a certain level of
abstraction nothing has changed right so
by this prism you can look at logic
programming and logic programming is
doing tensor algebra
okay um just help me understand this a
little bit so um you know the main the
main criticism of using a neural network
um as a combined computational and
memory substrate is that they it's a
finite state automata so without having
the um the augmented memory like a
turing machine you can't represent
infinite objects that's the main reason
the symbol is you know that's the main
argument I use so wouldn't that argument
still be leveled against you well no
because the the I'm glad you brought
that up because there is a very common
misconception if you realize that there
is no such thing as Infinity right and
in particular there is no such thing as
an infinite you know memory if that
problem doesn't arise so there's the so
the unfortunately a lot of theorists
including computer theorists uh they
they Foster this misconception right
yeah there's the Chomsky hierarchy right
with final automata at the bottom and
two incomplete you know tuning machines
blah blah at the top right if your
chewing machine has only a finite tape
it's a finite Autumn so everything is
just finite automata let's get that out
of the way right a lot of what people do
is like completely mistaken because of
that now the fact that everything is
final automata does not mean that
everything is equally good some
representations are far more efficient
compact etc etc for certain purposes
than others and the whole game here is
that like I'm not going to solve a final
automata the question is like what do I
need to do not because I need to go to a
higher level the Chomsky hierarchy
because in reality they don't exist but
because you know I mean
if you have infinite resources you could
solve it yeah with a lookup table
but would you would you not I mean for
example um there was this deep mine
paper that mapped architectures two
different levels of the Chomsky
hierarchy Transformers I think were you
know fsas uh rnns actually were one step
higher they could uh represent regular
languages and you've got context free
language I mean do you think there's any
meaningful distinction between those
language levels as I said there is a
meaningful distinction but it's not the
distinction that people usually make
because once you I mean you can debate
whether the universe is fine art but
certainly computers are finite so as far
as anything that you're going to run on
a computer there truly is no distinction
at this theoretical level between a
turing machine and a final automata that
does so like you I can reduce and people
have there are papers reducing you know
any of these things to any of the others
so it's like it's a fairly trivial
exercise so at that level those
distinctions are completely meaningless
however they are meaningful in the sense
that for many purposes I am better off
having an RNN than having you know a
Transformer and for many purposes I'm
better off so like let's take you know
propositional logic versus first the
logic right if there's no such thing as
Infinity first our logic is reducible to
propositional logic but that does not
mean that it's useless because it can
represent a lot of things exponentially
more compactly than proposition logic if
I want to represent the rules of Chess
in first order logic it's a page right
yeah if I want to represent them in
propositional logic it's more pages that
you can have okay well I think that
that's a very very good point but I mean
just just a devil's advocate from the
psychologist you know do you remember
that that photo fruition connectionism
critique paper and arguing productivity
and systematic productivity is all about
the infinite cardinality of language I
mean presumably you would agree that
language has an infinite cardinality no
well again another instance of the same
problem productivity is very important
but the point to just be a little
precise for a second is is to be able to
generate a vast number of things beyond
the ones that you started with vast not
infinite in fact mathematically Infinity
is not a number infinity is just a
shorthand for something that is so large
that it doesn't matter how large it is
okay
I mean at the end of the day I'm not a
mathematician but surely mathematicians
would push back on this because you know
Infinity is is a a quantity in
mathematics no I mean again
people in every field mathematicians say
this is computer scientists are often
guilty of the the the they have this
notational shorthand or like you know
this terminological shortening that
serves them well but then they be and
then they use that and then the newer
Generations come along and they and the
public also right they don't even
realize that uh what's being talked
about is a little bit different infant
is a perfect example any serious
mathematician will tell you that
Infinity does not have the properties of
a number so for example if I multiply
Infinity by 2 I still get infinity
there's no number that that happens to
yeah right so Infinity is is not a
number right when I say infinity is not
a number mathematicians might quibble
about the way I'm stating it but this is
this is a mathematical truth right
Infinity truly isn't out I'm being
co-local of course when I say that it's
a short term for something is so large
that it doesn't matter how large it is
when you take limits you know in
calculus in anything and the limit of
this blah blah as I go to Infinity this
is exactly what I'm doing I'm going to
the point where I'm saying like at this
point it doesn't matter how large the
number is the result will be the same
okay and in this way infinitely is an
extraordinarily useful concept so I'm
not here to rail against infinite I'm
just saying like we really need to
understand I mean let me give you a very
banal example right
um from the point of view of you know
what to have for lunch right because
some things cost more than others
um Elon Musk is infinitely rich
he does not have infinite money but it
makes no difference whatsoever whether
he has whatever 100 billion or 200
billion to what he's going to have for
lunch you know like hey you know a
street person who has five dollars to
them like their Fortune is not infinite
because it very much matters what lunch
costs right so this is the real sense of
infinity which we can and should use but
we shouldn't confuse it with like oh but
then you're you're you know like your
formalism is incomplete because it
doesn't Encompass Infinity yeah yeah it
doesn't need to Infinity doesn't exist
okay okay well let's come at it from
from the other from from the composition
compositionality and and um
systematicity so that's all about being
able to do you know like their main
argument was when you have a symbolic
representation you can kind of reuse
um the previous representations
Downstream uh composition uh
compositionally and when you take a
discrete symbolic representation and you
kind of encode it in the envelope of a
vector space you have a real problem
doing that because it's it's now like um
it's irreversible that trans information
right you can't go back to the to the
original variables well it is reversible
if you realize that all those real
numbers are actually finite
okay so notice that real number there's
nothing less real than a real number
real numbers are imaginary right real
numbers are numbers with infinite
Precision which is a monstrosity
and many people have said this including
mathematicians and physicists right the
notion of an infinite of a number with
an infinite number of digits is just
monstrous and again in particular on a
computer even if you use you know the uh
you know like numbers with unlimited
floating Point Precision right it's
limited by the size of your memory so
this transfer from which is actually
very important and again that's what
tensor logic largely is about from
purely symbolic structures to embeddings
in a vector space right yeah that Vector
space is still finite so there's
actually nothing irreversible about what
happened there interesting okay so how
can people um you know find out more
information about this and can you just
sketch out you know just just to bring
it home to people where they could
actually use it and how it would be you
know better than what they can currently
do right the answer to the first
question unfortunately is this this is
not published yet but but it will be
soon so for the moment uh there is no
very good place to point people too okay
unfortunately yeah uh but but that's
that hopefully will be fixed soon the
the
um the question of where to apply it is
our goal for this is that this should
become the language or hope I should say
our hope is that this will become the
language we're doing just about anything
in AI so for example if what you want to
do is actually nothing symbolic but you
just want to build a convenant you can
express a Content incredibly elegantly
in tensor logic yeah like if you think
of for example tensorflow or Pi Torch
versus numpy right they they allow that
thing to be said much more compactly
compared to tensor logic there are as
bad as numpy is compared to them right
same thing on the symbolic side but of
course the real action comes in all the
problems where you have both components
the problem with all those problems
which ultimately is every problem in AI
right you're always like what happens
today that is very frustrating and
that's what we're trying to overcome is
like you start from one of these sides
there's mainly the connectionist one
which you have a good Mastery of and
then the other side for example the
symbolic one the null representation the
reasoning the composability you just
hack yeah and your hacked solution is
terrible you're like you're inventing
the wheel you're making it Square you're
trying to make it turn but it's square
right it's just you know it's a disaster
and with tensor logic you can actually
have a very well founded very well
understood basis on either side so now
you don't have to hack either side now
there's of course little things that
you're going to have to hack at the end
of the day because at the end of the day
you know AI is intractable and things
are heuristic but this you know is
you know you know this notion of a
trade-off that is very important in
engineering I like people have been
exploring different points on this
trade-off curve the point of of of of of
uh tensor logic is that whatever your
application is
we move we're moving you to a better
trade-off curve it's still a trade-off
curve but but it dominates the old one
for any given X you have a better Y and
vice versa okay and just help me
understand because that we'll move over
to um you know the discrete program
search and some of Josh tannenbahn's
work in a moment but um there are two
schools of thought right there's
discrete first and there's continuous
first you're you're on the continuous
substrate but usually the reason for the
continuous substrate is stochastic grade
intercent learnability Etc et cetera and
like help me understand so are you
saying we start with a symbolic
representation and then we encode it
into the envelope so where does learning
come into it no very good so intensive
logic you can do broadly speaking two
kinds of learning you can learn the
structure of these tensor equations as
we call them using inductive logic
programming techniques again that whole
technology is there and the instruments
you have that you can learn the numbers
by by back prop in particular where it's
called back propagation through
structure because the structure can vary
from example to example but we know what
the type parameters are so all of them
is logic programming and all the machine
you have gradient descent and deep
learning or not they're both there
available to be used as you
traditionally have okay what if I made
the argument though that it's almost
like the inductive um logic you know
like the the program search that's the
hard bit so if you've already got the
program why do I then need to put it
into a vector space no actually these
are all so at the end of the day in
machine learning we're always trying to
learn a program of some kind right the
question is like what is the easiest way
to do that and precisely the problem
with ilps with symbolic logic is that's
really a couple of problems one is that
if all that you do you learn programs
that are too brittle and we don't want
them to be brittle right and the other
one is that
each type of search has it has its
limitations so in particular in symbolic
AI including ILP we tend to use a lot of
combinatorial optimization types of
search right what we in Ai call search
is discrete search and that is good in
some ways but also very limited in
others the same thing is true of
gradient descent right and now to go to
that for just a second
gradient descent is not a continuous
optimization algorithm it's not right
again those rule numbers are not
infinite Precision there's actually
nothing continuous going on in the
computer greatly descent truly literally
rigorously mathematically is a discrete
optimization algorithm it takes discrete
steps the assumption that gradient
descent depends on which is that the
infinites and with small updates do not
hold and moreover in machine learning as
a numerical analysis we are constantly
dealing with this fact that there's a
mismatch between our mathematical
conceptual model of the space that we're
working with as continues with the
reality of the computer that is not
continuous so great so now this is not
but great distance still is a different
optimization technique with some very
important advantages in particular the
key right the power of gradient descent
comes from the fact that to move from my
current point to a better one I don't
need to try out all the neighboring
points because that takes order of the
time of the neighboring points I have a
closed captioning not available
because you take a finite step right the
gradient descent is always taking finite
steps which is why it's a discrete
algorithm and and once you take that
finite step for any reasonable learning
rate the total effect of the
approximations that you've made
typically swamps
the step that you're taking so the
Assumption of calculus that we decent is
founded on is actually false now in some
ways this invalidates a lot of our
intuitions in many ways and again this
remains to be resolved a lot of why
gradient descent works better than
people expect it to is in fact that it's
doing something else it's doing
stochastic search partly because of the
SGD as opposed to being matched partly
because of things like this okay but
this is really interesting a couple of
places we can go but first of all I
remember you you did the the paper and
that that um introduced elements of ntk
theory as well which might be an
argument against the discreetness of the
optimization but also I wanted to trade
off the two types why is there an
argument against the discreetness well
isn't there with ntk isn't there like a
closed form solution doesn't that kind
of like erode the discreetness of the
optimization no I mean so there's
several things here but like if you have
a closed form solution absolutely
brilliantly go for it yeah right there's
nothing having a closed from solution
and knowing price that it's continuous
or discrete or any other thing right
does that so so let's say there was a
Place form solution and and it was like
an infinite kernel and it represented
some neural network that doesn't that
erode so first okay so first of all in
the work that so the work that I've done
that I think you're referring to is like
I have a proof that every model learned
by gradient descent is a kernel machine
yeah right and it's something called The
Path kernel which is the integral of the
of the neural tangent kernel you know
Over The overgraded Descent right yeah
and now the neural tangent kernel uh
does not assume that your network is
infinite most of the theory that people
have done with it assumes that the
network is infinitely wide but might but
but the the definition absolutely does
not require that and none of what I do
and in fact that's part of why you know
of its power is that it assumes no
Infinity of anything it's for any
architecture that you use and in
particular you know finite architectures
okay interesting okay so hence the
discreteness but right can we come back
to this contrasting of the discrete
program search and and the you know
stochastic gradient descent on on a
vector space now
um in the vector space uh there are
certain characteristics you know there
are certain symmetries and even though
it's a discrete search through the space
I would argue that it's still continuous
in nature it has certain characteristics
so contrast those those two forms
precisely so uh exactly I I mean I think
you've put your finger in now the whole
point of this continuous spaces right is
not that they're continuous because
again that's that's a fiction is that
they have a certain locality structure
yeah that you can exploit
to very good effect and this is exactly
what credentes sent us right now that
locality structure doesn't have to be
infinitesimal right you don't need
points to be infinitely close for all
this to apply approximately and again
they never are and it's always an
approximation now the question is do you
want to make these locality assumptions
or not right making them buys a certain
things right but it's also potentially
unrealistic in some ways right now this
actually to take a very concrete
instance of this think of space right we
model space in science in physics and in
anything as a continuous thing which it
is not right which is not to say that
and by the way physicists start coming
to this conclusion right these days the
prevailing views is the it from bit
thing is that like it's you know space
arises from entanglement etc etc space
is not the fundamental reality right and
now I think that where this is
inevitably going one way or another is
that we realize that space is discrete
right but and this is key it has certain
prop properties including symmetries
like translations in variance rotational
events Etc that hold approximately or
exactly but if those hold and a whole
bunch of things like that then you have
you know your latent variable structure
right is very well approximated by our
notion of continuous space in which case
it would be foolish to not use it right
to formulate the laws of physics and to
do computer vision and so on and so
forth but at the same time right if we
believe in it too literally we walk
ourselves into a blind alley so
concretely look at computed Vision right
people in the universe of computer
vision started out trying to do with
differential equations and for your
analysis and all of that good continuous
stuff right because that was the obvious
thing to do right and it failed that
doesn't work that's why we need things
like deep learning and you know Markov
random fields that are discrete grids
that use you know to model the images
and whatnot because you along with the
approximate continuity you also often
have large discontinuities and if you
can only model the world continuously
then you can you don't know what to do
and the problem precises that you have
all this phenomena that are like this
including you know Envision but also in
in turbulence and condensed metaphysical
you got to realize that there are
discontinuities and not try to shoehorn
them into continue the one that's no
longer appropriate interesting okay well
can can we bring in um ILP and can you
contrast like the kind of function
spaces that that are learnable in both
methods yep so
are your peers so let me actually
preface this with the following people
in every one of these schools of AI tend
to have this view that I can represent
everything in the world using my
Approach
so I could like look prologue it's
during complete so why do you need
neural networks but I can also say
neural networks are too incomplete so
why do I need prologue and in fact
kernel machines have a representative
theorem that says you can approximate
any function blah blah blah right so
everybody has one of these
representative theorems right that says
I can represent anything right so in
particular you can do right I mean look
first neurologic was invented by by
Friday essentially to to model the real
numbers so it can almost by definition
model real numbers right anything you
might want to say about real numbers and
and waiting to Centennial numbers and in
fact people have even done this exercise
you can say it all in in logic
programming right so why not just do the
well precisely because certain things
are much more easily done in other ways
right so what you have to ask about
anything but then about you know another
logic program in particular is like what
things are well represented in this way
like compactly represented and then in
such a way that learning them and doing
inference with them is easy right and
those things are different for logic
programming and for things like deep
learning which is why we need the
unification of both so what is things
like logic programming and ILP good for
right it's precisely I mean it's many
things but the key thing is it's
precisely for learning pieces of
knowledge that can then be reused and
composed in arbitrary ways this is the
huge power symbolic AI that connections
mechanism does not have right it's like
I learned the fact here I learned a rule
there and tomorrow you ask me a question
and I combine that fact actually several
Rules by rule changing right there's a
whole proof tree of rules that could
have come from very different places and
I do a completely novel chain of
inference that answers your question
this is spectacular right and this is
truly core 12 intelligence is all about
and the symbolists know how to do it the
connectionists don't but if I was a
connection I'd be like you know and if
it was a good one and the better ones
like your show benjam are doing this
right it's like go and try and
understand what those people understand
so that you can then not combine it with
those other ideas yes yeah yeah I
completely agree so a huge part of
intelligence is this um symbolic uh you
know extrapolation
yeah so
um how do you um bring abstraction into
this because I the thing that I always
get caught on is that the traditional go
5 Vision was to you know handcraft the
knowledge and actually what we need is
dynamic knowledge acquisition and we
need the ability to create abstractions
on the Fly rather than just what we do
now which is crystallizing existing
human abstractions how could we do that
bit well abstraction traditionally was
and still is a central Topic in in
symbolic AI right like be precise I mean
I think nobody questions that having
levels of abstraction someone is very
important the only question is how so if
you look at Classic knowledge
representation planning etc etc
abstraction is all over the place if you
look at things like reinforcement
learning and I mean even like you know
the whole idea or hope overconfident is
that it captures objects at multiple
levels of abstraction at least to some
degree in reality it doesn't right but
that's what people are trying to do and
and not quite doing right well good
let's let's touch on that then so I mean
certainly in yam the Coon's view I spoke
with Jan the other day he's got this
autonomous path a paper and he you know
his system is learning abstractions but
there are abstractions which are
deducible from base abstraction priors
like objectness and and you know basic
visual priors and so there's there's
this assumption that everything is
deducible from the prize that we put
into the model but um I have this kind
of intuition that abstraction space is
much larger than that yeah I mean so
I would even say that if if you arrive
at your abstraction solely by deduction
you have a very impoverished notion of
abstraction in fact most of inductive
learning is forming abstractions and
from abstractions at the most basic
level is something very trivial is like
I have an example described by a
thousand attributes
if from that I use the rule that uses
only 10 I've abstracted the way the
other 990. okay but but if if um if a
symbolist was here they would talk about
intention versus extension and they
would say that you know you're selecting
from this infinite set of possible
attributes You couldn't possibly
represent all of the attributes and they
said let me just give you a concrete
example you know you could have
um a a a a a a a a a a a you know I mean
you just have like this again I hate to
bring up Infinity again because that's
always what these folks bring up but um
how could you select from from a set
that large well I don't need to because
it is finite but what I need to do is so
so but there is actually a good example
and we you know Infinity doesn't need
not bothers at all at all there because
what's like if my training set right is
a set of strings and those strings are a
a a a a a a right going up to whatever
number you want to pick like you know a
million or a quadrillion you know or a
Google right then are is your learning
algorithm able to induce that the the
language that these rules come out of
right the grammar is you know it's a
series of A's right you and I can do
that immediately you know most deep
Networks have no end of trouble doing
that even though it's that basic so it
is a very good example of what symbolic
learning and reasoning can do versus
connection is you don't need to go
anywhere in the infinity to actually
have that be a very elegant example well
let me bring up just one other we've
touched on a lot of great things right
there's one in this space of things that
we've been talking about there's one
that I think is very important which I
believe you're also a fan of and I very
much am and I think it's going to you
know maybe going back to the question of
what I'm interested in that's happening
at murips right now or not so new
symbolic AI is definitely a big one yeah
another big one and to my mind maybe
these are the two biggest ones our most
interesting is is what I call symmetry
based learning and these days is more
popularly known by the by the by the
name of like geometric deep learning and
things like that I tend to view
geometric deep learning as a special
case of symmetry based learning yeah but
this idea of I think let me you know to
go straight to the punch line we know
that for example Ai and machine machine
learning in particular have as
foundations things like you know logic
probability optimization and I think
another Foundation is symmetry group
theory in fact I was having you know
dinner with with maxwelling just the
other day who who of course have also
interviewed and is you know like a great
you know person in this area and we you
know I think we have very similar views
on this well Pedro yesterday
um Taco kohen was sitting where you were
sitting so there you go yeah again I
remember talking with Taco at my similar
many years ago where he had published
one of the first papers on this yeah and
I was like and he seemed a little
disheartened by the lack of interest
that people had and I said to him just
wait this is going to be big and we're
there now right it's going to be even
bigger I think but also I think to
become bigger and again to jump straight
to the punch line most of the work
including me that people have done to
date has been exploiting known
symmetries like you know translation
invariance is the quintessential example
for example we have something called
dpfi networks that journalize as convex
to you know you know rotation you know
scaling etc etc this is all well and
good but I think if this is and and if
you look at new lips today for example
most is in that vein yeah and there's a
lot of good work to be done there but if
that's all we ever do we will always
remain a niche in AI with certain very
good applications like science
applications where we know that certain
symmetries hold and whatnot Max and taco
are doing things like that but I don't
want to just do that I really you know
I'm trying to make progress towards
human level Ai and I think the key there
is to discover symmetries from data yeah
and I think most of us agree with this
it's a hard problem right but that's
what we're here for we want to discover
symmetries from data and you know
there's an interesting you know
discussion of how to do that you know I
have a number of ideas and a number of
people have then the power of
discovering symmetry is Right connecting
back to our early conversation is that
symmetries can individual symmetries can
be very easy to discover because they're
often very simple but then right by the
group axioms axioms you can compose them
arbitrarily yeah which means I can for
example by learning a hundred different
symmetries of a cat from 100 different
examples then I can compose them and
correctly recognize as a cat
something that is extremely different
from any concrete example of a cap that
I saw before
could I push back on a tiny bit so I
mean in the the geometric deep learning
protobook I mean they spoke about and
you know the various symmetries of
groups like SO3 you know preserves um
translations and angles
um you know like how primitive and how
platonic are these symmetries and aren't
they just like obvious in respect of the
domain that you're in no very good so
this is actually a key question symmetry
group theory is one of them it's a
central area in mathematics that and
it's a very highly developed and it's
the foundation of modern physics like
the standard model is a bunch of
symmetries and so on but the way and
there is an exhaustive listing of what
all the possible symmetry groups are
discrete ones you know uh uh continuous
ones you know so called lead groups etc
etc so at that level this is not naive
because people already have a handle on
what the space is right but crucially
for our purposes for AI That's not
enough because precisely because those
again the analogy with logic is is
actually a very good one here here first
order logic is too brittle right and and
playing symmetry group Theory the way
people have mostly parts so far is also
too brilliant for the same reasons so
for example right something that you
know people almost always immediately
come up with say like oh I understand
you know what like symmetries would
allow you to recognize you know perturb
digits but a six is not a nine so some
like if you just think now you see much
a good theory and it's like well
arbitrary composability I was just
talking about like well now you've just
said that a six you've lost the ability
to distinguish a six from a night yeah
right now what we need precisely is to
combine symmetry group Theory with the
other things like statistics and
optimization and say something like the
following the space of things that you
can compose is unlimited you can have
you know unlimited compositions but for
example you pay a cost for composing
more symmetries and now when you find
the least cost path and that's how
you're going to match things or you know
your digit becomes less and less
probable to be in six the more you've
rotated it right so now we know how to
do all of that very well so we know
symmetry group Theory very well we know
how to do all these probabilistic cost
minimizing blah blah blah things and
machine learning very well we just need
to combine the two the same way that we
have previously combined these things
with first order logic so I'm glad you
brought in the cost that was really
really good so um there were trade-offs
everywhere I mean for example if you
want to make the models more fair and
you know prioritize the the low
frequency attributes on the long tail
the headline accuracy goes down same
thing with robustness if you robustify a
model the headline accuracy goes down
same thing with symmetry groups if you
introduce other symmetry groups you know
the headline accuracy
um goes down so it all comes back to the
biospherians trade-off at the end of the
day and you know where is the limit hit
like how how much can we optimize these
models and and what does good look like
the virus variance trade-off is a very
useful tool right but but it's not the
deepest reality right the the way to
think about bias variance is that what
again talking about this notion of a
trade-off curve there's a trade-off
between bias and variance right which is
in some sense unavoidable right in
machine learning if you have finite data
you're trying to learn powerful models
by experience is a trade-off and it's a
very consequential trade-off in the
sense that for example the things that
work best with small amounts of data
tend not to work best with larger
amounts of data right this is something
we should all you know grow up in
knowing in machine learning but so many
mistakes have been done because of that
because people study things in the easy
or historically that's all they had
right and then they're very surprised
when something that seemed not very good
like say deep learning right turns out
to be better when you have a large
amount of data or they believe in like
silly things like you know Occam's Razer
version that you know accurate you know
simple is more accurate and whatnot so a
lot of mistakes have been been made
because of lack of understanding of this
having said that what you really want is
to move to better trade-off grid between
virus and variants which you can if you
get at what the reality is right so the
real gaming machine once you're
evaluating your learner and figuring out
your like how much to prune and whatnot
or how much to regulate by experience is
very important but before that the most
important question is like what we're
trying to do here is figure out what are
the inductive biases what are the
regularities that the world really has
at least approximately that we build our
organs on top of that and then if you
give me a better one than I have now
I'll still have a bias variance straight
off but I'll be in a in a curve where
for the same variance I can have less
bias and vice versa and that's where the
real action is how interesting but I
didn't quite understand that because you
know bias invariants they are mutually
exclusive and I I thought at first you
were saying well if we understand what
the biases are better you know the the
prototypical symmetries of the world we
live in then then we can have more bias
without having no approximation error
basically the conclusion arises because
biases are very unfortunately overloaded
term right this is not even getting into
of the psychological notion of bias like
in you know then economists work or even
the sociological notion of ice like
racial biases gender biases and whatnot
so we need to distinguish like I just
used you know my bad the word bias into
completely different senses completely
but not unrelated that's the thing right
one of them is the statistical notion of
bias right that you know there really is
a trade-off between the two right
there's a sum of squares blah blah blah
right yeah the machine learning notion
of inductive bias it's the preference
that you have for certain models over
others which is really just another way
of saying your priors whether they are
assumptions or knowledge right you know
maybe actually they're saying instead of
by saying like what you really want to
do is figure out what are the priors
what are the model classes where the
preferences right advice is a kind of
preference that really line up with the
world in reality or the domain and
therefore let you move to a better
trade-off curve among statistical bias
and statistical variants
amazing well and Pedro um just tell us a
little bit about what what have you seen
at Europe's and and how's the week been
for you so we've already attached on
some of the interesting things that I
saw
um in particular some of the areas that
I'm interested in the thing about Europe
is this of course is that it's a vast
conference and in the early days I used
to at least go through the proceedings
and and look at you know the title and
maybe the abstract of every paper and
this is now impossible right now these
days if all you do is try to walk
through the poster sessions you never
get to the end right yeah I haven't been
to a single poster session in in this
Europe's where actually you know
actually got throughout I like to go
through the postal sessions quickly once
yeah and then you know just to see
what's there and then go back to the
ones that I found really interesting I
haven't actually been able to even
finish that walkthrough uh because
they're so vast right you also run into
people which is part of the point and
talk and whatnot but like when this 500
you know post is in every session and
there's three thousand papers in the
conference it becomes very hard to find
the ones that are most relevant of
course an easy thing to do is look at
the you know what the I mean
something about Europe's this year that
I honestly thought was absolutely
terrible like a really really terrible
idea is that uh you know it's a it's a
hybrid conference and you know their
idea of a hybrid conference is that
there are no talks the talks are all
virtual next week and nipses nips is
here you know to First approximation was
one big poster session which I mean it
to me this is just an incredibly bad
idea yeah so in that sense I haven't
gotten as much out of nips by this point
of the conference as I would have in
most years right there's also looking at
the papers that were usually selected as
oral but this time they call them oral
equivalent because there are no oral
papers but they still want to have that
distinction and and you know the number
of those papers these days is 160 or
something which is you know bigger than
nips and icml where you know some years
ago and usually from those papers some
of them kind of like jump out at you as
being great and very relevant I've only
looked at them briefly right so I you
know don't don't you know quote me on
this if you will but none of those have
jumped out to me uh you know as like oh
yeah this sounds like something really
brilliant and and that I want to dig
into but there probably are many I just
haven't you know really had a chance to
look at them yet yeah I mean I have a
similar reaction I mean it it feels like
um that we're at the point of saturation
and there are loads and loads of micro
variations on on the same idea it's
completely overwhelming but what I find
is that it's it's a very social
experience when I walk through the
posters I just immediately become
engrossed in conversation and hours go
by and I just think oh my god what have
I just been doing for the last and
that's the real point is the posters are
a very good you know it you know it's
like the grain of sand and the oyster
the post is the grain of sand the oyster
is the conversation that you have with
the person at the poster with or or with
other people around there to touch on
another point that you made that I think
is actually important
so you know in Europe it's a nice email
and so on are bigger today than they've
ever been right actually not strictly
two because this recently surprisingly
the tennis has gone down a lot you can
you know we can ask we can ask we can
and should ask why but
we need to scale
we you know like there are bigger
conferences like the new science
conference is one conference and it's 35
000 people you know every year and they
make it work I don't think and it's good
to experiment I I think you know near
upset the skill that is today can work
but it is not working very well one of
the ways in which it's not working very
well is that we need to think a lot more
and I understand this is working it's
hard and people have their jobs and
whatnot so this is not you know a
criticism in that sense of like we need
to really work on making it easy for
people to find the papers that are
relevant to them right number one number
two and maybe even more important there
is more machine learning research today
than ever
but in some sense the diversity of that
research is in some ways lower than ever
so another point that you brought up and
I think is very important to do with the
scaling of of European and the Machine
learning communities that we have in
just raw numbers more machine learning
and AI research going on today than ever
before by an order of magnitude but in
terms of diversity there's probably less
diversity in the research now than there
was before which is a tragedy right so I
understand why people have kind of like
converged to deep learning and you know
I'm a huge fan of deep learning right I
was doing it before it was cool as they
say and whatnot but the extent to which
like 90 of the community not just in
machine learning but but AI is not just
pursuing and not even deep learning but
a special type of deep learning which is
which you might call applications of
back prop is extremely
um undesirable right we have you know an
infinite number of micro Improvement
papers along a particular direction that
is almost certainly a local Optimum
right and we're just digging into the
local Optimum with every more papers and
never you know more you know minimal
publishable units when this large amount
of Manpower that has come into the field
or or you know or is moving around we
really need to have a greater diversity
of research in machine learning within
deep learning within Ai and and and you
know so like we are making very poor use
of our research you know Manpower right
now and we see that very much in
Europe's today yeah I mean Sarah hooker
talked about the hardware Lottery you
know being stuck in a basin of
Attraction determined by Hardware but
there's also an idea Lottery it might
just be the case that Europe's
historically has always been very
connectionist anyway I mean well it
hasn't right that's one of the irony is
but it's something I wasn't aware of
that okay oh absolutely not I mean in
fact the joke is right that uh nips
started in the 80s it was called neural
information processing systems right and
by the night as it should have become uh
bips for Bayesian information processing
systems right there was this study that
they did at one point of predictors of
acceptance and rejection among words in
the title and the biggest predictor of
rejection was the world mural really and
this was very famous in the field
because indeed ifsuka you know 1990
something you were submitting papers to
nips with the world knew all in the
title you didn't know what you were
doing and then in the in the 2000s right
it became bips or should have become
bips sorry Kips kernel information
processing systems yeah and in fact I
remember having lunch with Joshua
Benjamin at the SML in Montreal in 2009
and and we were talking about this right
the fact that every decade and you know
not a new paradigm but another one of
the same Paradigm seems to now be on top
right and you know you know he asked
like so what is the next decade going to
be and I said it's going to be dips deep
information processing systems and then
we both laughed and I could tell that I
believe this but he Joshua Benji was
actually skeptical of this so you know
the the deep and little did we know
right if somebody told us that you know
this is going to be on the page of the
on the front page of the New York Times
in a couple of years would be like what
are you smoking right so the way to
which this deck has been dipped is just
mind-blowing but looking for it right
and to this point of you know diversity
and research approaches I think if you
extrapolate naively from the past the
next decade will be about something else
and the trillion other question is what
what is that else going to be amazing
okay
um you watch trauma's talk right yeah
what's your high level View
I thought it was a nice talk I thought
it was a very appropriate talk for an
opening talk at the conference actually
if news had like some conferences a
dinner talk right which is supposed to
be interesting but not as you know deep
or as technical as other this would have
been the perfect dinner talk from
Europe's because the topic is very
current right our machine's sentient and
and you know who better to talk about it
than Dave Chalmers right the world's
expert on on on unconsciousness right
and and by and large I thought the talk
was excellent in fact you know when
journalists ask me questions you know
Consciousness is like one of their top
three right along with Terminator and
you know unfairness or something like
that right and and I will Point them to
this talk because it kind of like lays
out you know the uh you know the ground
uh uh and you know it's good for people
to at least have that those things in
mind
at the end of the day so I think of
course the notion that Lambda was
sentient is you know ridiculous as as
most of us do you could ask a slightly
more finer impression was if if
Consciousness is on a continuum
right which I think Dave believes in and
if you believe in like this you know I.T
Theory and fire and whatnot in like Phi
is never zero right so there's always
some Consciousness right pen psychism
and whatnot I'm not saying I believe in
that we could we could go into the but
like if you believe in that then you can
ask well on that scale you know where is
Lambda yeah where are these large
language models and and and surely
higher than previous AI systems right
but in my views still very very very far
and I think what you want to keep in
mind is that Consciousness does not
increase continuously precisely there's
these transitions where you go you know
more is different is the is the famous
you know phrase about emergence right
Consciousness is very much an emergent
you know phenomenon and I think what
happens is that there are points at
which your conscience will leap maybe a
thermostat does have Consciousness like
you know uh or or you know or purpose or
whatever right like like people in like
people like McCarthy for example had had
that as an example but the amount of
Consciousness is minuscule and and that
and and the way I will put that is that
these large language models still have
not passed that first threshold
interesting so so in a similar way to
some of the discussion about large
language models there are kind of
scaling uh breaks in the levels of
consciousness I mean Charmers made the
comment though that rather than it being
a pure Continuum he said that a bottle
was not conscious but then there was a
kind of no yes so the key Point scaling
is part of it but not only
it's not just so your cortex to First
approximation is a monkey brain scaled
up right
there was a module there that evolution
discovered and it really paid to keep
making more and more of it and we can
easily speculate why but the point is so
let me contrast two things right which
is true for Consciousness but also for
just AI in general like there a lot of
people are scaling Believers and like
open AI is the poster child of this in a
quite conscious ways like we're just
gonna scale the heck out of things and
then a lot of people like you know Gary
Marcus being a good example they just
completely poo poo that they say like oh
no this is a joke right and I think the
truth is that scaling is good right
again you know part of what we are our
intelligence is scaling but but the
question is what are you scaling and the
things that we're scaling today it
doesn't matter how much we scale them we
never get to human level intelligence or
Consciousness so I think we need some
fundamentally different algorithms if
you want to think at the level of
algorithms or fundamentally different
architecture
architectures if you want to think about
it anyway and then scaling those up at
some point will give us Consciousness if
you live that it's possible for a
computer to be conscious but we're not
there yet either in terms of the scaling
although actually scaling is actually
the easier part of this way we're
actually at the point where computer can
have the same amount of computing power
that that your brain does which was not
the case before but the bigger deeper
problem and the more fundamental one is
like we need the architecture to scale
right and this is where I sympathize you
know with people like Jeff Hinton who's
just you know playing with you know
ideas using Mathematica and very small
examples which in some ways sounds very
underpowered but I think it's people
like that they are going to come up with
the things that we then scale as in fact
it was David romerheart doing that kind
of work that invented back prop right if
he hadn't invented backpack this whole
industry would not exist so what I think
is that the real back prop the real
master algorithm is not there yet and we
need to discover that first and then and
we and then when we scale that up which
will not be drivable but will be much
easier by comparison then we'll have you
know human level intelligence
Consciousness Etc interesting okay and
so Charmers is a um a structuralist
computationalist so you know he thinks
information not biology and um he's also
uh um
a functionalist right so you know which
which is very similar to um to behavior
and you know Hillary Putnam made the
move that you can kind of like represent
a computation in any open physical
system and he kind of like used that on
you know if you if you follow that line
of thought it almost trivializes
computationalism because it you know it
leads to pan psychism very very quickly
so so first of all I mean what's your
take on this idea that information could
give rise to intelligence and
Consciousness so I agree like most
scientists and I think in particular
most computer scientists that to a first
approximation the substrate does not
matter and in particular you're not
going to convince me that something is
not conscious just because it's not
biological there is no reason to think
that only biological things can have
Consciousness now the deeper problem and
you know indeed the hard problem is that
so as Dave Chalmers defined it so
there's a basic Fork here which you've
alluded to which is
if Consciousness is subjective
experience then all these questions
about Consciousness are ultimately
unresolvable because
only I have my subjective experience I
know that I'm conscious no one can
persuade me of the contrary I don't even
know if you are conscious let alone some
machine right so if if Consciousness is
an intrinsic property of something that
cannot be evaluated from the outside
then we're doomed we're never going to
answer this question and maybe that is
the case right so I'm not saying that's
false and you need to always keep that
in mind but now if we're going to make
any kind of progress right we need to
look at what are to to generalize a
well-known term the external correlates
of Consciousness right one of those
which has been well studied by people
like Christoph Culkin and so on and I
think that's a very good direction is
the neural correlates of Consciousness
right what goes on in your brain that
correlates with conscious and we've made
a lot of progress with that you can also
talk about what are sort of like the
informational computational quality of
Consciousness are there computational
structures that support Consciousness
and the ones that don't I think that is
also useful thing to do less develop it
actually anxious dispense psychism
because it's not like everything is
conscious just because it can compute
some computations after this emergence
and these you know phase transitions may
give rise to Consciousness whereas
others it doesn't matter how much of
them you have they will never be
conscious so I think this is also a very
useful way to make progress on this
question and one to which AI versus you
know a neuroscience or psychology is
very well suited to interesting so on on
the functionalism point and I think
Charmers has been very very consistent
he uses this uh kind of calculi to
reason about intelligence as well so a
system is intelligent if it can perform
reasoning if it can perform planning if
it has sensing and so on so we have this
collection of functions and then he's
kind of like moved this over to the
domain of of Consciousness so similarly
if a system performs these uh these
functions
um and is used it in a positive and a
negative way so some functions would
indicate an absence of Consciousness and
some functions would
um you know lead to the presence of
Consciousness and it's kind of like
leading towards a uh you know Turing
test for Consciousness I mean do you
kind of support that that so yeah that's
a very interesting question in fact you
know I was having dinner with with Dave
after his talk and I actually brought
this up because it wasn't clear from
from from his talk and I said look this
is the answer that I usually give to
journalists when they ask me you know
will machines ever be conscious and
whatnot and and ask me if you and then
ask them if you agreed with it and
actually expected him to disagree but
but I think again don't want to put wood
in his mouth but but that he agreed
right and and the answer is the
following is is that
human beings right as we've discussed
have an amazing tendency to enter
performize things it's reasoning by
analogy and what happens I used to say
this is what's going to happen at this
point is this is what is already
happening is that as soon as a machine
behaves externally even vaguely like its
Consciousness we immediately start
treating it as if it's Consciousness so
if you look for 10 25th years from now
we will just treat AIS as if they're
Consciousness and people won't even ask
that question they will assume they are
conscious in the same way that we assume
that each other that we're conscious
right and but then and so like from that
pragmatic external point of view maybe
the question is answered right but you
could be a philosopher or like sort of
like a very you know a rigorous you know
technical person and it's like no no no
no I really want to know if things they
may look you know conscious from the
outside but are they really right but
that question as far as I can tell
unfortunately at the end of the day is
probably an unanswerable now there's a
middle ground between these two things
that maybe Israel will wind up and and
to me sounds like probably the best
thing that we're going to be able to do
which is that like our understanding of
the neural information Alex Etc
correlates of Consciousness evolves to a
point where we have the feeling that we
do understand Consciousness it's not
just the layperson calls this
Consciousness it's not like Lambda is
not conscience you know poor Bozo Etc
it's like you know there are many
analogies to that in the history of
science there used to be a lot of things
that that were like magical right and we
were like oh we're never going to stand
like life was magical right life did not
obey the laws of physics it's just
something else right this sounds
laughable right now but it wasn't
laughable at all then right and now it's
not like we've understood everything
about life very far from it we're saying
like there's DNA and there's cells and
this is how it all arises right and I
think we're at the point in
Consciousness we're still like oh
Consciousness is some so beyond this
right I think we will get you know they
will be a structure of DNA moment in the
history of the study of Consciousness
and I think yeah I think things like Phi
and this you know it3 and whatnot the
very brave attempts to make progress in
this direction I think you know like
Juliet is you know
very deluded in thinking that he has
nailed what Consciousness is right I
think you know five maybe is is an upper
bound on Consciousness but with steps
like this hopefully at some point and
very much with the help of AI right AI
is really useful for this because it's a
brain that might be Consciousness that
we have a lot of control of and you can
do experiments that you can't you know
with people right so I think we will
make at least some progress in that
direction for sure maybe to the point
where we feel that yes we do understand
what Consciousness is we're not asking
ourselves that question anymore and then
we can point to things and say this is
conscious that this is that kind of
Consciousness that amount of
Consciousness and so on yeah that's
really interesting I agree we're making
a lot of progress in getting a handle on
this and although um the the biggest
game in town is still the
computationalism game and as you say
historically the only alternative was
mysterianism and my friend Professor
Mark Bishop that he said that that's one
of the reasons why he's become
interested in the four reason cognitive
science because For the First Time It's
given him a kind of robust alternative
to computationalism but just coming back
quickly and you know as Chalmers
reference Thomas Nagel you know which is
that it is something it is like to be a
bat what do you think about that so um
I'm not sure what your question is but
let me search I mean do you do you agree
that there is something it is like to be
about oh absolutely right so there is
more more and more than that right there
is something that it's like to be about
and it's very different from being a
human right and we grossly underestimate
right again we do this thing that again
it's a heuristic it works very well it's
like we project ourselves into the bad
because what else could we do right but
then what you see is a bad scene through
the mind of a human right and in fact
there's this famous I would say even
more famous you know you know notion
from from Wittgenstein right that if the
lion could talk I would not understand
anything
that the lion was saying yeah because
his world is so different from mine now
I actually think I think this is a very
important position to as a reference
point right certainly defensible one and
you know Wittgenstein was a good
defender of it but but I actually think
that this is going too far I think
ultimately I may never be able to
completely know what it's like to be a
lion but we can make a lot don't
underestimate us either right we can
make a lot of inwards into understanding
what it's like to be a lion much more
than we understand today same thing for
a bat and you know you could have also
asked that for a fruit fly right in a
way fruit flies more different from us
than a lion but it's easier to
understand right because at some level
that thing is so simple that we can
understand what's going on with it
because it's not that deep yeah that's a
beautiful quote actually
um so so closing this off do you think
that large language models are slightly
conscious or will be in the near future
I think language I think large language
models are not slightly conscious by the
reasonable you know everyday definition
of The World Slightly meaning that their
Consciousness so either I think that
either their Consciousness is just zero
right if somebody asked me like you know
how much you know conscience is this you
know Lambda have tell me in one word and
the answer would be zero right but
another answer which is hard these
things from the first one is Epsilon
right maybe it has a very tiny amount of
consciousness
but it's so tiny that it doesn't even
qualify slightly again this gets back to
what his architecture is I it actually
gets to a lot of things but
for purposes of this discussion right
Lambda and these large language models
are not very different from a big lookup
table any big lookup table is not
conscious now I mean there are a lot of
interesting distinctions that you can
make it well what if what I have is an
efficient approximation to a lookup
table isn't that what your brain is
right and and I would say yes and and
then people say well but then why is
you're being conscious about not the
lookup table right and and precisely the
interesting question is that the
Consciousness comes about from the fact
that you have to concentrate all of this
information you know you know in real
time into something you know very
Compact and that leads to action
continuously right so to put this in
another way maybe God is in
Consciousness because it doesn't need to
be right if you're omnipotent and
omniscient you don't need to be
conscious you are effectively just the
lookup table
I loved your response earlier about the
grain of sand and the oyster I thought
that's a beautiful way of looking at it
and and having recently studied so I
mean personally I I think it's a lot to
do with intentionality an agency but I
remember you responded to that just
final quick quote a final quick fire
question what's your definition of
intelligence
so let me start with the technical
definition which is unfortunately not
widely known enough and not appreciated
enough but I think it's a really
important one to have right intelligence
is solving NP complete problems using
heuristics
this is the real technical definition of
AI right and there's a lot packed into
that right the fact that it sent me
complete problems and the fact that it's
using heuristics if your problem is
solvable with the lookup table with
polynomial algorithms you don't need
intelligence and there's no intelligence
there it's when you start solving hard
problems using heuristics that you're
getting into the realm of intelligence
moreover NP complete is not the same as
exponential right The crucial thing
about an NP complete problem that
connects very directly to our entire
discussion of utility and whatnot is
that the solution is easy to check
this is the key if you're working on
problems with solution is impossible to
check effectively I can't even tell if
you're intelligent or not the whole
thing about intelligence in humans and
machines is that how you solve the
problem requires a lot of intelligence a
lot of computing power and whatnot but
then I can easily check the solution but
hang on it's better because that's a
step away from Behavior then if you're
saying that the you know like you have
the percepts the state and the action
and and you're saying the state is also
important no so to to answer that
head-on intelligence is not Behavior
right intelligence to to to give a
slightly more general definition and
then there's several and they all have
their nerds intelligence is the ability
to solve hard problems and then more
concretely it sent people complete
problems and using heuristics but like
for example if you create an AI system
that cures cancer
it doesn't behave in the sense that a
human and a robot behave but but you
know it's them intelligence it's more
intelligent than we are right it would
be churlish to deny intelligence to that
system no matter how it solves cancer if
it sounds a ridiculous simple if it
finds a ridiculously simple way to solve
cancer then it's even more brilliant
right in fact the simpler your outcome
the more intelligent you are right it
takes intelligence to produce something
simple wow concretely in many
circumstances in particular Evolution
right intelligence manifests itself as
Behavior there's a sequential
decision-making problem there's an agent
in the world that said Etc so it's being
a stochastic part and I think also from
you know theoretical Reasons by
analyzing what a Transformer can
represent and how it can learn my best
guess which could be wrong again I don't
think anybody has the answer to this an
interesting question is that
those let's Transformers right not llms
is more of like a task rather than the
you know the the architecture
Transformers have a certain limited
ability to the compositionality very
limited to compared to full logic
programming Etc but exponentially better
than something like an ordinary
multi-layer perceptron yeah and if you
just I mean even a multi-layered
perceptron or any learning algorithm is
more than a stochastic parent because
it's gen the whole point of machine
learning is to generalize beyond the
data if you generalize correctly beyond
your data you're not just a parent
anymore and you know I I think it's not
an accident that that term stochastic
parrot came from Emily Bender my
Linguistics colleague UW who does not
understand machine learning
she is a classic linguist of the
chomskin variety who does you know does
not fundamentally understand what I
think you know she might disagree what
machine learning is all about and she
would probably look at any learning
argument say that it's a stochastic part
missing the fact that the whole point of
machine learning and the thing that we
focus on from you know beginning to end
is generalizing and as soon as you're
generalizing correctly even if you have
no compositionality you're you're
already doing something that's that has
a little bit of intelligence and that's
beyond let's look at what a parrot would
do yeah I mean to be fair it's not it's
not a binary and at the time I thought
they were stochastic parrots as well
I've I've updated my my view and you
were talking as well about creativity
there's a kind of blurred hyperplane of
creativity and we discussed you know
where that hyperplane
um sits but you know what's really
interested me I've interviewed quite a
few people that are working on working
on in-context learning in these language
models and it seems like these language
models are almost almost like a new type
of um compiler you know you're writing a
program inside the language prompt and
they seem to work extremely well outside
of the training range if you're doing
like basic multiplication tasks I think
it is useful to look at them as any type
of compiler in fact I've been saying for
a long time that uh you know like
there's there's this Continuum from
programming in assembly code to
high-level languages to doing AI right
the point of AI is to continue along
that path to making the language that
computers speak ever closer to ours so
that we can just program them by talking
to them or writing things at them right
having said that I think that you know
what goes on in the innards of a
transformer right is actually still
um
very primitive for lack of a better word
right there's a lot
of so something I tweeted that got a lot
of follow-up from people like Jan and
Gary and and who the pro because they
were all bringing in their own angle so
this was like I said and I think this is
an interesting question it's like the
interesting question about Transformers
is what needs to be added to them to get
real intelligence so we should not deny
what they have like the attention
mechanism in particular right and the
embeddings and the content so like there
are two very important things in
Transformers that are beyond what was in
neural networks 10 years ago and and our
key one of them is attention right
attention is a real advance and the
other one is context-specific embeddings
right each of these ideas is important
in its own right and combining them
together is very powerful right again
because the context sensitive embeddings
get that the similarity part of
intelligence the attention combined with
the context sensitivity of the
embeddings gets at the compositionality
part so so they do have so they are a
couple of steps forward on the road to
human level intelligence but there are
many more and rather than you know
either say like oh they're just parrots
they don't do anything we're saying like
we've almost solved the eye what we
really should we should try to
understand better you know how how the
you know the attention and the context
dependent
um embeddings work which we don't but we
also need to focus like now what are we
still missing because we definitely are
and that's really where most of our
focus should be yeah I completely agree
and also just in defense of vendor I
mean I I think she's a brilliant
linguist and and I personally think
having that diversity of views from
different people is is useful no I mean
I so uh I very much think that having a
diversity of use is very important and I
think something that I'm always saying
to my deep learning friends who can't
stand you know who hate the guts of Gary
Marcus is we really really need informed
critics yeah and very typically your
informed critics are not people in the
field we are experts but then we also
suffer from the Distortion of being
experts it's people in a just in
adjacent areas and people like linguists
and psychologists are very much those
people they're in adjacent areas enough
to have a good critique of AI so for
example something that young is always
throwing at at Gary Marcus that kind of
uh doesn't see well me says like well
you should try building a real system
sometime and you can criticize us until
we do if we take the attitude that only
Engineers can criticize Engineers we're
doomed right having said that there is a
very big distinction between the
knowledgeable informed critics like Gary
Marcus and the Not So knowledgeable not
so well informed ones which
unfortunately Emily is an example I mean
she's my colleague at UW and I've talked
with her about some of these things and
her criticism of machine learning
unfortunately like a lot of people comes
from a place of actually not
fundamentally understanding it very well
but people these people do say that Gary
isn't an expert in deep learning and and
that he's you know attention seeking
what would you say to that no he's he's
he is not an expert in deep learning and
you know so like
I agree with some of his criticisms I
disagree with with others probably on
balance I disagree more with him than I
agree but so first of all there is a
value having critics like that number
one but then number two
the reason his criticism I mean it would
be better if he was also an expert in
deep learning and made the same
criticisms and then the problem is that
often his criticisms are wrong because
he has a mental model of deep learning
that is already outdated or is
oversimplified right yeah but that is
some degree is unavoidable but the thing
that makes this criticism valuable is
that he's doing it at a level where on a
good day on a bad day his criticisms
miss the mark but on a good day which is
the ones that matter his criticism is
actually useful because it's at a level
where you don't need to understand the
details it's like you claim to be
producing intelligence I as a
psychologist know a lot about
intelligence that's what I study for a
living right he knows more about aspects
of intelligence than I do yeah and and
from that point of view what you're
doing is lacking and and that I mean
like he's written the whole books about
you know again because this goes back to
when he was a PhD student and you know
in symbolic learning and whatnot there
are very you know uh the the Deep
learning folks have repeatedly
underestimated how well he understands
some of these problems because as a
psychologist in particular interested in
language learning he's actually thought
very long and hard about them oh I know
so I've read his his book and we've had
him on the show three times which book
um the algebraic mind yeah so that's
yeah like relevant one here yeah as a
psychologist you know he spent a lot of
time studying how children learn rules
right and he talks very elegantly about
a compositionality and we've spoken
about this it's irrefutable and I agree
with him and we've supported him I I
guess
um some of the things he argues are
based on ethics politics and virtue and
and some of the things like
compositionality I think are irrefutable
I mean I think irrefutable is a very
strong word I wouldn't say that they're
irrefutable I would say that they have
they have very strong backing which the
connectionists have not been able to
effectively refute but some of the
criticisms that they had
you know meaning people like Pinker and
Prince and whatnot famously of
connectionists in the 80s some of them
are still valid which is very Salient
but some of them not really and again to
go back to the daddy of this whole
school of thought who's Chomsky right
his you know he made his name basically
panning things like you know Markov
models of language engram models which
you could say large language models are
just a very glorified version of right
but and at the time you could that
criticism was very apt and and you know
and timely and it was useful right but
but but and famous dislike is like you
can't learn a context-free grammar but
context program is what you do well
actually now we know formally that you
can learn a context free grammar and and
what you know because you only have to
learn it probabilistically which is what
we do and what our systems do so his
criticism was just you know
mathematically Off the Mark but also
when you look at systems that do speech
language etc etc it is that statistical
approach that he made his name planning
that has prevailed and for reasons that
we understand very well and large
language models are just the latest
greatest expression of that so at that
level a whole Chomsky and Pinker Gary
Marcus view of things not only is it not
irrefutable it has been refuted hmm okay
let's just quickly come back to your
definition of intelligence so um solving
NP hard problems I assume you would zoom
out a little bit and you know it's more
of a meta learning algorithm so the
ability to sell to solve different
problems
yes so it's if very good point if all
you have is the ability to solve one NP
complete problem that does not qualify
as general intelligence right there's
there's like these days this is a common
definition to make this different
difference between uh you know narrow
intelligence and and general
intelligence and AGI and whatnot right
and if you only solve one NP compute
problem very well you have narrow
intelligence is the way I would put it
but you do not have general intelligence
general intelligence is precisely the
ability to solve a a limitless variety
of problems all that have this
characteristic of they're hard to solve
but the solution is easy to check right
I mean if you have the ability to solve
problems whose solution isn't easy to
check then maybe you're intelligent but
I can't decide whether intelligent or
not interesting okay and um actually um
Gary did uh he put a paper out about 20
years ago talking about how neural
networks can't extrapolate I think it
was when he encoded numbers with a with
a binary encoding or whatever and um
we've been on a bit of a journey on on
this so we had Randall Bella striara
I've been interviewed him yesterday he's
got this paper called the spline theory
of neural networks that basically says
that a neural network decomposes an
input space into these input activated
polyhedra and when we first read that we
felt that it kind of
um indicated Francoise assertion that
neural networks are locality sensitive
hashing tables and they only generalize
within you know these tiny polyhedra and
Randall's now updated this view to say
in contrast to decision trees these
hyper planes they actually inform a lot
of information in the extrapolative
regime outside of the training race so I
always thought it was the inductive
prize that gave the extrapolative
performance on on neural networks by
photocopying the information everywhere
and um so like you know this is a great
example of where you know Gary might
update his views because even basic MLPs
are far more extrapolative than anyone
realized
this is a very interesting question but
the way I would put it is that in that
regard in some sense both of the sides
are right and the reason they're both
right is that we're in very high
dimensional spaces yeah and we're in a
very high dimensional space the
following thing can happen which is you
know you have a data point and you
generalize to a vast region around that
data point and it's unfair to
characterize these things as saying they
just interpolate in some sense they
really do extrapolate
but at the same time that vast region
that they generalized correctly to is an
infinitesimal fraction of the much much
faster reason that they have not
generalized to but you and I can
so so you've got to keep that
distinction in mind and then in
particular right
um I like to say that deep learning is
nearest neighbor in curved space
and both parts of that are very
important right so you know Jan uh lacun
was was famous
um you know during the Glory Days of
Kernel machines for saying that kernel
machines are just glorified template
matches right and of course they didn't
learn many friends but he was right they
really are just glorified template
matches kernel machine is really a
souped up more mathematically elegant
and blah blah blah version of nearest
neighbor right and the new slavery is
just a template matcher the building
department is neighbor though is that
there is a neighborhood within within
which often it generalizes very well
right now I think what Jan was missing
and I probably still is is that
coordinates and deep learning they are
still just a they are also glorified
nurse neighbor except more glorified
and the way in which they're more
glorified it is very important is that
they are doing new slavery in curved
space
they are still just doing you know the
generalization by similarity which you
could argue is all that machine learning
does is generalizing by similarity
another notion of similarity can vary
right but the important thing that
they've done is that nearest neighbor
just uses some distance to measure in
the original space whereas the neural
networks are warping the space to make
the problem easier for the nearest
neighbor you know essentially dot
product-based similarity uh uh
computation that they're actually doing
oh sure but you're very much arguing um
this is the way Francois chole puts it
that you know you have all of these um
uh Transformations and and you kind of
um distort the space you know to
represent the data manifold and you know
you want it to you you stop SGD at the
right time so that you approximate the
data manifold and you can do this kind
of latent space um you know
interpolation on the geodesic of that
manifold but you know Randall's idea is
is completely away from that idea of of
you know these models learning this
curved space and so if you do slice the
space face up with these hyper planes
rather than it being a locality prior
which is what you're talking about these
hyper planes give you globally relevant
information to things that are you know
miles away from the training data yeah
so but these two perspectives are are
more similar than you might think
because I can take a distorted version
of space and decomposing the polyhedra
right and one or the other might
approximate what's really going on
better I mean these new networks do form
code spaces except that in practice
they're not good because they're finer
but but ignoring that right
wait let me put it this way an eloquent
example of this is if you look back at
the original space right again treat
this thing as a black box where does it
generalize to does it generalize only
two things new networks as we have them
today does it generalize correctly only
to things that are locally
near the data point or you can
generalize well to things that are far
right and the thing is that with nearest
neighbor You by you know almost
intrinsically you only generalize period
at all to things that are local
the beauty of of deep learning and of
the space wrapping that's going on is
again going back to this notion of the
path kernel is that you're actually
doing a nearest neighbor computation not
just in a space that swap but you're
doing it in the space of gradients which
actually means that you can generalize
correctly to things that are very far
from your examples except they look
similar in gradient space a very simple
example of this is a sine wave right if
I try to learn the sine wave using
nearest neighbor I need an infinite
number of examples right because you
know like what I've learned over here
helps me not at all with the next turn
of the sine wave like that continuous
extrapolation right at some point
there's this disaster where if the last
piece of the sign was going up and just
keep going up and getting more and more
wrong right and in fact this kind of
thing does happen in neural networks but
they also have the part to say like and
this again this also happens which is
I'm going to transform this space more
into more intelligent one which is the
space of the slopes right and now if
I've seen one cycle of the sine wave
with some density of examples
by similarity in that transformed space
I generalized correctly and trivially to
every other turn of the sine wave so
there's a very big fundamental
difference between the two interesting
and you think with an MLP it would be
possible to have that kind of
extrapolative generalization on a slime
well so people have studied this in in
multiple ways and the problem so the
question is it depends on what are the
um
basis functions that it's using yes so
something that would interlude to at all
in this conversation but analyze all
this is like what is your choices basis
functions right yeah and the thing is an
MLP with the traditional say Sigma or a
little basis functions will not learn
this no matter for obvious reasons right
yeah and again you can represent it
right the representative theorem is
there like like the sine wave is just
one sigmoid and then another one you
know with a minus sign and then another
one but the data doesn't let you learn
it yes right if as a basis function you
have sine waves which is nothing
unimaginable that's what if Fourier
transform is then then you can learn it
so easily it's not even funny so it
depends dramatically on the basis
function and the question really becomes
what are the basis functions in the and
the architecture that let me generalize
correctly to a lot of things including
this such that for example and this is a
very simple test it's like I can nail a
sine wave with a small number of
examples without it being one of my
basis functions yeah exactly and then
this all comes back to you know we're
talking about inductive price and the
bus variance trade-off and even
symmetries actually I mean the taco
Cohen once said that
um you know if if you encode all of the
um the symmetries into the label
function then you would only need one
labeled example so as well as a
trade-off between how much induction are
you doing well uh interesting you should
say that I understand why he says that
and it's and it's not technically wrong
but I would say that practically what
you need is is such a set of symmetries
per region of the space right per
cluster right but but but you know in
another way I would actually make an
even stronger statement which again is
very perfectly mathematical is an object
is just the sum of its symmetries or a
function if you tell me all the
symmetries every last one of an object
you've defined the object
so if I can learn the symmetries at that
level I don't need anything else of
course as we already discussed that's
not the whole answer likewise with any
function if you tell me all the
properties of the function there are the
you know to be more precise all the
symmetries of a function at some point
you've told me the whole function and
vice versa from the function I can you
know I can read out all the symmetries
that it has in principle doing that in
practice can be you know very difficult
and subtle thing to do that's a
beautiful thing to say you give me the
symmetries and I'll give you the object
yeah exactly amazing Professor Pedro
Domingos thank you so much for joining
us today it's been an honor thanks for
having me amazing